ओके
सो चलिए तो हम लाइव आ चुके हैं एंड आई
थिंक एवरीथिंग इ
गुड यप ओके सो गुड इवनिंग गाइस गुड इवनिंग
सबको कैसे हैं आप लोग क्या हाल चाल है
सबके जल्दी से बता दीजिए एक बार गुड गुड
सबको गुड गुड
इवनिंग
चलिए सबको आने देते हैं एक बार फटाफट और
आते आते ही लाइक ठोक दीजिए जल्दी से जल्दी
से लाइक ठोकिए आते ही आते
चलिए एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
क्लियर आवाज जा रही है आप सबको बढ़िया
से ओके ठीक है तो ओके यहां पर कितने लोग आ
चुके हैं यहां पर 15 लोग आ चुके हैं बाकी
सबको आने दे देते हैं शनि हेलो हेलो शनी
रकी
हेलो शांके थारा भाई जोगिंदर ठीक है मोदित
अ ठीक
है मिस्टर एंट तान्या भारद्वाज नचिकेत गुड
इवनिंग हितेश गुड इवनिंग सबको गुड इवनिंग
काफी लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पे 25 लोग अभी आ
चुके हैं हमारे साथ तो हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
बहुत ही जल्द और आज का सेशन बहुत कमाल का
होने वाला है सबसे पहले सबको वेरी वेरी
वेलकम एंड गुड
इवनिंग ठीक है
शुभ
सायंकाल
[संगीत]
ओके आइए आइए जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी और शेयर कर
दीजिए आज के भी सेशन का लिंक ग्रुप्स में
जहां जहां आप शेयर करते हैं जितनी जगह
शेयर करते हैं व ग्रुप्स में या कहीं पर
जहां शेयर करते हैं वहां शेयर कर दीजिए
ताकि बाकी लोग जुड़
जाए गुड इवनिंग चलिए मारिया गुड इवनिंग
अफताब गुड इवनिंग ए टू जड शॉट हेलो हितेश
हेलो हेलो शैलेंद्र यस गौरव ठीक है जाफ
फैज ओके फैज को जाफ लिखा
है सिमी हेलो
सिमी कोट स्टार थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू
चलिए ए साइलेंट है ओके
ओके
ओके सो इसको पढ़ेंगे क्या
शंकी क्या
पढ़ेंगे चलो गुड इवनिंग
सो ओके गाइस सो आज का जो हमारा सेशन होने
वाला है बहुत ही कमाल का होने वाला है
बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन आपके लिए होने
वाला है एंड आज के सेशन में हम एक बहुत
ही चीपर अल्टरनेटिव को देखने वाले हैं ऑफ
एडब्ल्यू एस एंड बहुत बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है मतलब आपको समझ में आएगा आप आपको जब
पता चलेगा तो आपको लगेगा कि अरे यार
एडब्ल्यू एस में इतना कुछ करना पड़ रहा था
यहां तो कुछ नहीं करना पड़ रहा यहां तो
आराम से मेरा काम हो जा रहा अब मुझे आप
लोग बताइए एडब्ल्यू एस प आप में से कितने
लोगों का अकाउंट क्रिएट होके एंड कितने
लोगों ने मुझे बताइए कितने लोगों ने आप
में से एड्स प अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लिया था
फ्री ट्रायल जो अकाउंट था एंड इंस्टेंस को
लच कर दिया था कितने लोगों का हुआ था
जल्दी बता दीजिए
फटाफट लेट मी नो राधे राधे राधे राधे पंकज
हेलो पंकज
हेलो सर आईम आल्सो लर्निंग बग बाउटी आई
हैव क्वेश्चन बिल्कुल क्वेश्चन पूछिए
बिल्कुल
पूछिए क्या बात है आज तो 50 प्लस भी नहीं
हो पा रहे हैं क्या करें यार डिस कंटिन्यू
करे क्या इस सीरीज को आप लोग क्या करते हो
यह यार
बताओ ओके काफी लोगों का हो चुका था चलिए
अब आपसे मैं पूछता हूं क्या आपको मजा आएगा
जब मैं आपको एक ऐसा प्लेटफॉर्म बताऊं एक
ऐसी तरीके बताऊं जो
एडब्ल्यूएसयम आपको कितना मजा आएगा और लाइफ
टाइम आपको सस्ता पड़ेगा बहुत ही शानदार
बहुत ही शानदार मतलब मजा आ जाएगा आपको उस
प्लेटफॉर्म पे काम करके उस प्लेटफॉर्म पे
अ वीपीएस लच करके या क्लाउड उस क्लाउड को
उसके क्लाउड सर्वर्स को यूज करके आपको मजा
जाने वाला है ठीक है तो आज हम उसी को
देखने वाले हैं उसी के बारे में बात करने
वाले हैं बहुत कुछ बट उसके पहले मैं आपको
सीधा-सीधा एक चीज चीज बता देता हूं हमारा
डिजिटल फॉरसिस का एक थ्री मंथ्स का लाइव
ऑनलाइन ट्रेनिंग जो है वह लॉन्च हुआ है जो
27 जन से स्टार्ट हो रहा है इस ट्रेनिंग
के अंदर सिर्फ सेवन सीट्स अब बचे हुए हैं
सात ओनली सात सीट्स बचे हुए हैं तो अगर आप
चाहते हैं तो इस वाले लिंक पे आकर ton.com
digitalf5 में भी आपके यहां पे पेस्ट कर
देता हूं आपको चैट में भी ये लिंक मिल गई
होगी और ये हमारा linkedin.com
दोनों ही कर सकते हैं तो
चलिए
सॉरी चलिए तो आज सेशन स्टार्ट करते हैं
एंड आज का जो टॉपिक है आज काफी मजा आने
वाला है
आपको बढ़िया आई कंप्लीटेड पोर्ट स्कर
मल्टीपल लैब्स बट नॉट कंप्लीटेड परफेक्ट
एंड मल्टीपल डाउट्स व्ट नेक्स्ट स्टेप आई
डू ट्राई कीजिए कंप्लीट करने का सारे
लैब्स को एंड रिपीट कीजिए प्रैक्टिस कीजिए
एंड तब आपको ज्यादा बेटर समझ में आएगा
जितनी प्रैक्टिस करेंगे उतना आपको समझ में
आने वाला है प्रैक्टिस कम होगी समझ में कम
आएगा बस ट्स इट इतना ही मैं बोलूंगा अभी
आपके लिए ठीक है जितनी प्रैक्टिस उतना समझ
में आएगा आपको
राइट तो आज जो है गाइस हम बहुत ही एक कमाल
की प्लेटफॉर्म देखने वाले हैं जानने वाले
हैं एंड इस प्लेटफॉर्म पर मैं आपको पहले
ही बता देता हूं हम क्या करने वाले हैं हम
गो वी आर गोइंग टू सेट अप क्लाउड फॉर बग
बाउंट एट चीपर रेट चीपर रेट देन एडब्ल्यू
एस एंड विथ मोर
ईज ठीक है काफी इजली आप इस पर कर पाएंगे
पहली बात इजी टू यूज है आपका यह
प्लेटफॉर्म यह जो मैं आपको एक अल्टरनेटिव
बताने वाला हूं ठीक है मोर स्पीड वर्चुअल
मशीन की बात करें तो कहीं ना कहीं आपको
एडब्ल्यू एस से कुछ बेटर स्पीड और अच्छी
आपको जो रिजल्ट्स है आप आपको यहां पर
मिलने वाले हैं आपने एडब्ल्यू एस का किया
था आपने देखा था अब एडब्ल्यू एस में एक
चीज मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं गाइस मैं य प
एड्स को ओपन करता हूं एंड आई एम गोइंग टू
शो यू
समथिंग आई एम गोइंग टू साइन
इन ठीक है मैं यहां पर साइन इन कर रहा
हूं जब मैंने एडब्ल्यू एस
का
ओके जब मैंने आपको एडब्ल्यू
एसयूआरएल 5 दिन पहले का जो यह लाइव सेशन
था इसमें काफी लोगों ने पूछा था कि इसका
कुछ अल्टरनेटिव बताओ सर जो इससे सस्ता भी
हो और इससे बेटर आपको परफॉर्मेंस दे तो
वही मैं आपको आज के सेशन में बताने वाला
हूं पूरा कंप्लीट इन डेप्थ एनालिसिस एंड
कंप्लीट इन डेप्थ जो है ना प्रोसेस करेंगे
हर हर एक चीज प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे एंड उसको
हम देखने वाले हैं ठीक है चलिए आज का सेशन
ज्यादा लंबा नहीं होगा बट काफी यूजफुल
होने वाला है अब देखिए यहां पे एडब्ल्यू
एस में यहां पे आप बेसिकली आएंगे यहां पे
टू इंस्टेंसस पे ठीक है एक चीज मैं आपको
और बता देता
हूं एंड ये कौन से इंस्टेंस का नाम
अ लेट मी सी चलिए इसी इंस्टेंस पे आएंगे
यहां पे तो आपका इंस्टेंस यहां पे रनिंग
दिखता है यहां पे जो जो इंस्टेंस आपके
रनिंग है आप यहां पे देख सकते हैं
राइट ओके अब मैं यहां बैक करता हूं मैं
यहां पे एक लच इंस्टेंस पर क्लिक करता हूं
एक बार फिर से मैं आपको एक चीज दिखाता हूं
यहां नीचे आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको इंस्टेंस
टाइप आपको दिखेगा ये इंस्टेंस टाइप दिख
रहा है आपको t2 ये t2 माइक्रो t2 ननो फ्री
यर एलिजिबल यानी जो फ्री ट्रायल आपका
अकाउंट है उसके लिए ये t2 माइक्रो ही
एलिजिबल है बाकी में आपका फ्री टियर वाला
एलिजिबिलिटी नहीं है बाकी में आपको
चार्जेस लगेंगे जो आप बाकी यूज करेंगे बट
अब मैं नीचे आता हूं नीचे आता हूं यहां पे
बहुत सारे हैं t2 मीडियम t2 एक्स लास यहां
पे ऊपर चलते हैं t3 मीडियम t3 t3 सीएस ठीक
है यहां पर और भी आते हैं यहां पर देखते
हैं c5 c6 नीचे की तरफ और भी कुछ है क्या
c6 ओके t4 प एक बार देखते हैं कुछ है क्या
करेंटली ओके अभी यह अवेलेबिलिटी नहीं
है ओके इन द सेंस कि यहां पर आपको सिर्फ
क्या मिलता है एक आप को मिलता है क्या t2
माइक्रो जो आपका फ्री टियर एलिजिबल है
यानी कि फ्री टियर वाला अकाउंट आप इस पे
इसको चूज करके जब आप बनाएंगे इंटेंस तो
आराम से आपका चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
फ्री ट्रायल यूज होगा एंड आप उसमें कर
पाएंगे काम बट जैसे-जैसे आप इसमें ज्यादा
यूज करेंगे बैंडविथ वगैरह ज्यादा यूज करने
लगेंगे तब तब वैसे-वैसे ये बहुत ज्यादा
जल्दी यूटिलाइज होगा और आपकी कॉस्टिंग भी
बढ़नी शुरू हो जाती है ये एडब्ल्यू की बात
है अब आज जो हम देखने वाले हैं जो समझने
वाले हैं वो बहुत ही एक शानदार प्लेटफॉर्म
है एंड इस प्लेटफॉर्म का नाम
है डिजिटल ओसन इस प्लेटफार्म का नाम है
डिजिटल ओसन अब इस प्लेटफार्म पर आके आपको
क्या करना है साइन अप करना है लेकिन कैसे
करना है मैं आपको बता देता हूं
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक दिया है वह एक रेफर
लिंक है जो मेरा खुद का रेफर लिंक है आपको
उस लिंक से जाकर साइन अप करना है आपको
यहां पे $200
का यूएसडी जी हां 200 यूएसडी की मैं बात
कर रहा हूं 200 यूएसडी
200 का फ्री क्रेडिट मिलेगा जिसको आप यूज
कर पाएंगे एंड आप अपनी मशीनस को उस $ से
चला पाएंगे यानी $ मिलेगा फॉर 60
डेज यह देखिए ठीक है एक तो आपका एडब्ल्यू
हो गया चलेगा उसको रखिए आप अपने पास उसको
भी रखिए उसको भी आप साइड में रखिए उसको भी
यूज कर सकते हैं कीजिए अपने अकॉर्डिंग
जैसे जैसे ज्यादा यूटिलाइजेशन लगे आपके
पास एक अल्टरनेटिव आ रहा है डिजिटल ओसीएन
एंड इसका आप मैं आपको बता देता हूं लिंक
जो है ना
लिंक साइन अप यूजिंग लिंक
इन वीडियो या लाइव डिस्क्रिप्शन इस ये
मेरा खुद का रेफर लिंक है आप इससे अगर
जाके साइन अप करेंगे तो आपको $200 जो है
वो मिलेगा और मुझे भी प्र क्रेडिट मिलेगा
ओबवियसली है क्योंकि रेफर तभी इस होता है
एंड आपको $200 मिल जाएगा मेरे को $200
नहीं मिलेगा $25 मिलेगा वो भी जब आप $5
स्पेंड करते हैं तब अदर वाइज नहीं मिलेगा
ठीक है तो आपको $200 यहां पे आपके अकाउंट
में मिल जाता है अब मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
यहां पे मैं यहां पे लॉग इन करता
हूं ठीक है यहां पर मैं लॉग इन कर रहा हूं
लेट्स
सी लेट्स लॉग
इन गुड इवनिंग एवरी बडी गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग सॉरी देखिए आपको चैट में मिल गया
होगा सॉरी डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक
होगा उसी लिंक की बात कर रहा हूं
मैं यह देखिए यह अभी ओपन हो गया लॉगइन हो
गया अभी फिलहाल तो मैंने जस्ट ओपन किया
आपको दिखाने के लिए जस्ट और कुछ भी नहीं
यहां पे यहां पे जब मैं माय यहां पे मैं
रेफरल लिंक प जाता हूं एक बार रेफरल लिंक
प मैं चला जाता हूं एक बार लेट्स
यह देखो जो मैंने आपको लिंक दिया है वह
लिंक आप जैसे देखो यहां पर गिव $ गेट 25
एवरीवन यू रेफर गेट्स $200 इन इन द
क्रेडिट ओवर 60 डेज वंस दे हैव स्पेंड $5
विथ अस यू विल गेट 25 मतलब आप $5 स्पेंड
करोगे तभी मुझे मिलेगा अदर वाइज मुझे नहीं
मिलेगा आपको लेकिन $ मिल ही जाएगा ठीक है
तो लिंक जो है मैं वापस से डाल दे रहा हूं
चैट में डिजिटल ओसन लिंक टू
गेट चलिए लिंक में भी डाल दिया है एंड
आपको मैंने डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी इस वीडियो
के डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी डाला हुआ है ये तो
आप वहां से भी जाकर साइन अप कर सकते हैं
साइन अप करने का सब मैं अभी बताऊंगा कैसे
क्या करना है आपको अभी मैं दिखा देता हूं
यहां पे सिंपल यहां पे मेरे अकाउंट में
चलते हैं शायद यहां कुछ दिख
जाएगा
ओके यहां पे अकाउंट में देखते हैं
ठीक है यहां पर अकाउंट में यह दिख रहा है
आपको एंड इज देर
एनी
ओके अब यहां पर चलते हैं बिलिंग में राइट
बिलिंग प एक बार चल देते हैं लेट्स गो टू
द बिलिंग सेक्शन मैं आपको वो क्रेडिट दिखा
देता हूं एक
बार
ओके ये रही ये
रही ये आपको बिलिंग सेक्शन में दिख रहा है
यहां पे एंड यहां पे आपको अ ये चीज दिखेगी
देखिए ये चीज आपको दिखेगी ये अवेलेबल
क्रेडिट 200 ठीक है तो $200 मिल चुकी है
अवेलेबल $200 है
एक्सपाइरेट्री है थोड़ा वेट कीजिए इंतजार
कीजिए सब कुछ आपको पता चलने वाला है ठीक
है तो $200 को आप यूज कीजिए सबसे बड़ी बात
क्या है वो भी मैं आपको बताऊंगा वो भी
उसके लिए भी आपको टेंशन नहीं लेनी है ठीक
है बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज मैं बताऊंगा बहुत
सस्ता पड़ता है बहुत चीप मैं आपको अभी
दिखाऊंगा कितना सस्ता पड़ता है आपका आप
सोचोगे कि यार वाओ क्या बात है बहुत ही
चीपर है चलिए अब क्या करना है यह देखते
हैं पहले तो मैं यहां पे साइन आउट कर लेता
हूं तो व्हाट यू हैव टू डू आपको इसी
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाना है पहले
तो वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा आई
थिंक यहां से मैं डिस्क्रिप्शन चेक कर
सकता हूं
क्या एडिट पे जाके चेक होगा हां एडिट पे
जाके चेक होगा ये वाली लिंक आपको मिल
जाएगी ये वाली लिंक मिल रही है ठीक है ये
वाली लिंक डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगी
साइन अप टू टू डिजिटल ओसन फ्रॉम हियर टू
गेट 200 फ्री क्रेडिट $200 का अभी मिल रहा
है आपको ये $100 ही देते हैं जनरली बट अभी
ये $200 आपको दे रहे हैं तो अभी आपको डबल
मिल रहा है सीधी सी बात है ठीक है उस लिंक
को कॉपी कर लीजिएगा सिंपल लिंक को कॉपी
करके यहां क्लिक करके यहां पे आ जाइएगा इस
लिंक से आप आ जाइएगा यहां पे ठीक है जैसे
ही आप आइएगा यहां पे यहां पे आएगा योर
$200 क्रेडिट यू हैव बीन इनवाइटेड टू
डिजिटल ओसन साइन एंड गेट अ 260 डे क्रेडिट
टू ट्राई र प्रोडक्ट्स स्पेंड $25 आफ्टर
क्रेडिट स्वाय हु एवर फरड गेट ठीक है उसके
बाद गेट स्टार्टेड पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा
जैसे ही क्लिक कीजिएगा अकाउंट क्रिएट करने
का आएगा आपको ईमेल से अकाउंट क्रिएट करना
है ईमेल से कर लीजिए अगर आपको
[संगीत]
googleupdate.exe ये सब डालेंगे एंड
दैट्ची कार्ड है अमेरिकन एक्सप्रेस है या
यूनियन पे डिस्कवर कोई भी है डेबिट कार्ड
या क्रेडिट कार्ड आप इसमें यूज कर सकते
हैं अपने
यह कार्ड बेसिकली इंटरनेशनल डेबिट कार्ड
है एंड मास्टर कार्ड है बट मैंने इससे जब
ट्राई किया बेसिकली इससे लाइक आई ट्राइड
टू ट्राइड टू लाइक साइन अप हियर वेरीफाई
कि करने का तो नहीं हुआ फेल्ड हो जा रहा
था फिर मैंने एचडीएफसी का मेरे पास एक
कार्ड है इंटरनेशनल कार्ड एचडीएफसी का ये
वीजा कार्ड है मैंने इसको यूज किया एंड ये
एचडीएफसी कार्ड वर्क कर गया यहां पे
इंटरनेशनल पेमेंट्स इनेबल होना चाहिए आपके
कार्ड पे याद रखिएगा एंड देन मैंने उसी का
यूज कर लि तो जैसे ही मैंने कार्ड डाला
उसके बाद मैंने उसको वेरीफाई किया वेरीफाई
करते टाइम ₹1 155 डिडक्ट हुए हैं जी हां
₹1 जो है एग्जैक्ट डिडक्ट हुए हैं एंड ये
रिफंडेबल होते हैं आपके चार्ज वो नहीं
लगेंगे वो रिफंडेबल होता है यहां आप लिख
रहा होगा यहां देखो ये लिखा हुआ है ना वी
वांट चार्ज योर कार्ड यू मे सी अ टेंपररी
प्री ऑथराइजेशन चार्ज टू वेरीफाई द कार्ड
व्हिच विल बी रिवर्स विद इन अ वीक जो भी
चार्ज होगा जैसे 415 डिडक्ट हुए ना वो एक
वीक के अंदर आपको वापस से रिवर्स हो
जाएंगे आपका वो पैसा नहीं यूज होगा नहीं
लगेगा ठीक है तो टेंशन आपको उसके लिए
बिल्कुल भी नहीं लेनी है समझ में आया तो
यहां कार्ड की डिटेल्स डालिए सेव पेमेंट
मेथड पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा जैसे ही सेव
पेमेंट मेथड पे क्लिक करेंगे आपका ये
ओटीपी मांगेगा ओटीपी आप डाल दीजिएगा आपका
एंड यहां पे ट्रांजैक्शन आपका हो जाएगा तो
₹1 का मेरे पास ट्रांजैक्शन का आया हुआ था
जैसे ही हो जाएगा ट्रांजैक्शन यहां पे
आएगा कार्ड एडेड सक्सेसफुली तभी आप समझिए
का कि आपका काम हो चुका यहां फेल्ड आएगा
तो मतलब नहीं हुआ है वो कार्ड यूज़ नहीं
हो पा रहा है या चल नहीं पा रहा है तो आप
फिर से ट्राई कीजिए दूसरे कार्ड से तो
यहां आएगा योर फ्री ट्रायल हैज बीन
एक्टिवेटेड
दैट्ची क्लाउड स क्लाउड सर्वर यूज़ करना
है हमें क्लाउड मशीन यूज़ करनी है तो हम
अभी फिलहाल क्या करेंगे कुछ भी नहीं
करेंगे एक्सप्लोर टू आवर कंट्रोल पैनल जो
ऊपर ऑप्शन है एक्सप्लोर टू आवर कंट्रोल
पैनल बस उस पर क्लिक करेंगे एंड कंट्रोल
पैनल पे सिंपली हम मूव ऑन कर जाएंगे जैसे
ही आप मूव ऑन करेंगे कुछ इस तरह का
कंट्रोल पैनल आ जाएगा एंड यहां लिखा आएगा
योर क्रेडिट्स आर एक्टिव क्रेडिट
एक्सपायर्स इन 59 डेज एंड रिमेनिंग
क्रेडिट इज
00 बस ये लिखा जाएगा ट्स इट आपका साइन अप
प्रोसेस कंप्लीट हो चुका चलिए ये तो मैंने
आपको दिखा दिया अब
हम यहां पर आ जाते हैं कंट्रोल पैनल में
साइन इन कर लेते हैं अगेन साइन अप आई होप
कि साइन अप आपसे हो जाएगा राइट आई होप कि
साइन अप आप आराम से कर लेंगे सभी लोग कर
लेंगे ना साइन अप बहुत इजी है कोई ज्यादा
टफ तो है नहीं साइन अप प्रोसेस
राइट टफ तो नहीं है ना भाई साइन अप कर
लोगे ना सभी लोग बता दो एक बार बता दो हां
तो कार्ड बिना ऐड किए नहीं होगा भाई मेरे
बोल तो रहा हूं डेबिट कार्ड क्रेडिट कार्ड
कोई सा भी कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं सॉरी कोई सा भी कर सकते हो नो इशू एट
ऑल चलो मैं इसको डिस्ट्रॉय कर देता हूं एक
बार नो इशू एट ल कोई सा भी कार्ड यूज करो
डेबिट
क्रेडिट यह मैं मेरा एक ड्रॉपलेट था उसको
डिलीट करर ताकि आपको मैं फ्रेश दिखा पाऊ
सारा कुछ बिल्कुल एकदम स्टार्टिंग से दिखा
पाऊ
चलिए
ओके तो इस तरीके से आप आएंगे जब आपका
कंट्रोल पैनल लॉगइन हो जाएगा कंट्रोल पैनल
पे आप आ जाएंगे आपके डिजिटल ओसन के कुछ इस
तरह का इंटरफेस आपको देखने को मिलेगा यहां
पे आपको डिफॉल्ट जो है ना फर्स्ट क्लाउड
करके ऐसा कुछ लिखा हुआ आएगा या ऐसे कुछ
फर्स्ट प्रोजेक्ट लिखा आएगा फर्स्ट
प्रोजेक्ट ऐसा कुछ लिखा आएगा जिसको कि आप
चेंज कर सकते हैं ओबवियसली सेटिंग्स में
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आप उसका नाम वगैरह चेंज
कर सकते हैं जो भी आपको चाहिए नाम दे
दीजिए मैंने डेनिक्स यहां पे नाम दे दिया
है एक प्रोजेक्ट होरहा है यहां पे इसमें
क्या होता है एक प्रोजेक्ट होता है और उस
प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर में बाकी सारी काम जो
है आप करते हैं तो यहां पे मेरे प्रोजेक्ट
का नाम मैंने डेनिक्स रखा हुआ है अब इसके
अंदर डिफरेंट डिफरेंट चीजें जो है वो हम
करने वाले हैं पहले सभी लोग रिप्लाई कर
दीजिए तभी मैं आगे बढूंगा क्योंकि आप में
से बस दो-तीन लोग रिप्लाई करते हैं बाकी
लोग पता नहीं क्यों नहीं रिप्लाई करते हैं
आर यू नॉट गाइज इंटरेस्टेड मजा नहीं आता
आपको बता दीजिए वो भी बताइए आपको मजा नहीं
आता
क्या सभी लोग रिस्पांस कीजिए कि आपका साइन
अप हो जाएगा डिजिटल फॉर डिजिटल ओसन पे आप
लोग साइन अप कर लेंगे कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं
आए बता दीजिए
मुझे साइन अप आप कर
लेंगे प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी नो साइन अप हो
जाएगा
आपसे ओके 56 पीपल आर हियर सभी का रिप्लाई
आ जाता है देन आगे बढ़ते
हैं
ओके ठीक है ठीक है चलिए बढ़िया बढ़िया
बढ़िया
बढ़िया ठीक है ठीक
है चलिए बढ़िया ओके अब एक चीज और मैं
बताऊंगा जो भी बग बाउंट हंटर्स है ना
फॉरेन में जो भी बहुत सारे कंट्रीज में बग
बाउटी हंटर जो है ना वो डिजिटल ओसन को यूज
करते हैं एक्चुअली एक्चुअली यूज करते हैं
काफी सारे लोग
दूसरे क्लाउड सर्विस को भी यूज करते हैं
बट डिजिटल फ सॉरी डिजिटल ओसन को काफी लोग
यूज करते हैं
राइट ओके तो आप लोग ये लिंक जरूर आप लोग
जो लिंक है वो लिंक रख लीजिएगा आप लोग
लिंक को कहीं पे कॉपी पेस्ट मार लीजिए ठीक
है जो लिंक मैंने यहां पे चैट में आपको
दिया हुआ था हमारा जो रेफरल लिंक है उसको
आप कॉपी पेस्ट मार लीजिए ठीक है कहीं पे
कॉपी पेस्ट मार के सेव कर लीजिए उसी लिंक
से आप साइन अप कर लीजिएगा सेशन के बाद में
भी कर सकते हैं या जब भी आप चाहे कर सकते
हैं ठीक ठीक है तो लिंक जो है वापस से
आपको भेज दिया वो मैं लिंक को पिन कर देता
हूं
ओके लिंक को पिन कर दिया है उस लिंक प
जाके आप साइन अप करेंगे एंड आपको $200 जो
है वो मिल जाएंगे ठीक है चलिए अब क्या
करना है इसमें कैसे आप अपनी क्लाउड में
मशीन लच कर सकते हैं वो मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं चलो बहुत आसान है बहुत शानदार तरीका
यहां पे जब आपने ये आप नया प्रोजेक्ट भी
बना सकते हैं कोई और प्रोजेक्ट के लिए ठीक
है डेनिक्स प आपना ये जो प्रोजेक्ट है बना
हुआ है आपको चेंज करना है यहां जाके चेंज
वगैरह कर सकते हैं नाम जो भी नाम डालना
चाहते हैं जैसे मैंने डि फोनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कर दिया या जो भी आप नाम देना
चाहते हैं दे दीजिए ठीक है अब हमें डिजिटल
ओसियन के अंदर इंस्टेंस नहीं क्रिएट करना
होता ठीक है डिजिटल ओसियन के अंदर यहां
क्रिएट वाले ऑप्शन प आप जाएंगे ऊपर में जो
क्रिएट बटन है सॉरी तो इसके सारे ऑप्शंस
जो है यहां पे आपको दिखने लगेंगे
क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं क्यूबर निटस
ड्रॉपलेट्स एप्स फंक्शंस डेटा बेसस
वॉल्यूम ब्लॉक स्टोरेज स्पेस ऑब्जेक्ट
स्टोरेज डोमेन डीएनएस क्लाउड फ फायरवॉल्स
रिजर्व्ड आईपीस या लोड बैलेंस व्हाट एवर
दे आर सर्विंग ऑल दीज सर्विसेस इसमें
हमारे काम का क्या है यह है ड्रॉपलेट्स
हम डिजिटल ओसन में इंस्टेंस को या जो मशीन
है क्लाउड में उसको ड्रॉपलेट्स बोलते हैं
एंड हम यहां पे यह देखो नीचे लिखा हुआ है
क्रिएट क्लाउड सर्वर्स तो हम ड्रॉपलेट्स
को क्रिएट करने वाले हैं हमारे को जो
चाहिए वो ड्रॉपलेट्स हमें अभी बाकी चीजें
नहीं चाहिए वी नीड ड्रॉपलेट्स फॉर नाउ
यहां पर ड आ चुका है तो मेरे को थोड़ा वेट
करना है ताकि आप लोग देख
पाए वी नीड टू क्रिएट ड्रॉपलेट्स उसके
पहले अगेन मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा देता हूं
बता देता हूं यहां पर आप माय अकाउंट में
जब जाएंगे या बिलिंग पर
जाएंगे यहां पे बिल्डिंग पर चलते हैं
पहले
ओके बिलिंग पे आप आएंगे यहां पे नीचे आप
आएंगे यहां पे नीचे आ आएंगे तो यहां पे एक
बिलिंग अलर्ट्स का ऑप्शन आएगा बिलिंग
अलर्ट्स इस पर आप ऐड अलर्ट कर दीजिएगा एंड
यहां पे आप बता यहां पे आप मेंशन कर
दीजिएगा कि $0 $ जो भी है लाइक $0 आपने
अलर्ट दे दिया एंड सबमिट कर दिया यानी कि
जैसे ही $0 जो है ना वो होगा आप यूज आप
करेंगे वैसे ही आपको एक ईमेल पे अलर्ट आ
जाएगा कि आपने $10 का जो है यूटिलाइज कर
लिया $0 आपके आ चुके हैं सो प्लीज राइट आप
उसका ट्रैक रख सकते हैं ताकि ज्यादा एक्स
आप ना करें
राइट गुड इवनिंग डीजे सॉरी थो लेट हो गया
जवाइन करने में कोई बात नहीं कोई कोई
टेंशन नहीं है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आप बने
रहिए एंड सीखते रहिए चलिए य आप देख रहे
होंगे मेरा जो वीजा कार्ड है यह यहां पर
वीजा डेबिट कार्ड य लगा हुआ है एंड ट्स इट
अब आ जाते वापस से प्रोजेक्ट पर अब हमें
क्या करना है क्रिएट करना है एंड क्या
करना है ड्रॉपलेट तो ड्रॉपलेट पर मैं
क्लिक करूंगा
जो मेरे साथ करना चाहते हैं साथ में कर
सकते हैं कोई है जो मेरे साथ-साथ कर रहा
है अभी जो अभी जो रेफरल लिंक से गया साइन
अप भी कर लिया उसने एंड कंट्रोल पैनल में
लॉगिन भी हो गया कौन है भाई इतना फास्ट
मुझे बता दीजिए कौन है इतना फास्ट जो मेरे
साथ अभी तक साइन अप कर लिया एंड मेरे साथ
साथ अभी यहां तक आ चुका मतलब कंट्रोल पैनल
प आ चुका
बताइए कोई है भाई कोई है कोई बात नहीं मैं
जस्ट पूछ रहा हूं अगर कोई है तो बता सकता
है नहीं है तो तो भी कोई टेंशन नहीं
है ठीक है चलिए आई डोंट थिंक कोई
है ओके नचिकेत इज देयर बढ़िया नचिकेत साथ
में कर रहा है ओके नचिकेत ठीक है बढ़िया
बहुत अच्छे मिस्टर बीस्ट फैन ओके ओके
ब्रदर एक और एक और बंदा है वो भी कर रहा
है चलो अच्छी बात है अगर कोई साथ में है
तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं अब यहां पे आपको
क्रिएट प आना है एंड जब आप लोग साथ में
नहीं कर रहे हो ना तो बाद में आप वीडियो
को देख के प्रैक्टिस की वीडियो को देखिए
कैसे कैसे क्या और उसको फिर प्रैक्टिस
कीजिए
राइट ओके ओके तान ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया यहां
पर आपको क्रिएट पर क्लिक करने प आपको
ड्रॉपलेट्स प आना है ड्रॉपलेट्स पर क्लिक
करेंगे आपको क्रिएट ड्रॉपलेट का ऑप्शन आ
जाएगा ठीक है ड्रॉपलेट्स आर वर्चुअल मशीनस
दैट एनी वन कैन सेट अप इन सेकंड्स यू कैन
यूज ड्रॉपलेट्स इदर स्टैंड अलोन और एस अ
पार्ट ऑफ लार्जर क्लाउड बेस्ड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर यह क्या है एक वर्चुअल
मशीनस है वर्चुअल मशीनस में चल रहे एसस है
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है अब यहां पर आपको आके
चूज करना है रीजन देखिए रीजन चूज करते
टाइम बहुत ही ध्यान दीजिएगा रीजन चूज करते
टाइम क्योंकि आपका यह रीजन जो है इसका
मतलब है कि यह डेटा सेंटर्स है डेटा
सेंटर्स के बारे में अगर नहीं पता तो वह
सर्वर्स जो आपको सर्विस प्रोवाइड कर रही
है डिजिटल ओशियन की एंड आपके सबसे नजदीक
जो होती है वोको ज्यादा बेटर स्पीड
प्रोवाइड करती है समझ में आ रहा है यह सेम
उसी तरीके का लॉजिक है कि जितना नजदीक आप
राउटर के जाते हैं उतनी अच्छी स्पीड आपको
मिलती है किसी पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस में
इंटरनेट की जितने नजदीक आप डेटा सेंटर को
चूज करेंगे अपने उतना अच्छा स्पीड मिलेगा
आपको आपके वर्चुअल सर्वर की जो क्लाउड में
आपका मशीन चलेगा तो ओबवियसली इंडिया में
हूं मैं तो मैं बेंगलोर वाला सर्वर ही चूज
करूंगा सबसे नजदीक बेंगलोर वाला है जिसका
कोड है
आरव ट्स इट तो हमने बेंगलोर वाला सर्वर
चूज कर लिया वीपीसी नेटवर्क इनका जो
डिफॉल्ट है यह डिफॉल्ट ही रहने देंगे
इसमें हम कुछ नहीं करेंगे यहां अब आएंगे
चूज एन इमेज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन सा आप
इंस्टॉल करना चाहते हैं बहुत इजी है यार
इसका इंटरफेस य वनटू करना है फेडरा डेयन
सेंटोस एलमा लिनिक्स रॉकी लिनिक्स कौन सा
करना है भैया मैं तो चलूंगा डेवियन के साथ
क्योंकि डेवियन पर बेस्ड है हमारा
काली है ना य बन टू तो डेवियन ही यूज कर
लेते हैं ना क्या दिक्कत है आप य बटू भी
ट्राई कर सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं आप य
बटू भी इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बट डिजिटल ओसन प आपको डेवियन या य बन
टू में से कोई सा भी चूज करना चाहिए एंड
दोनों ही शानदार काम करेंगे इससे कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ता है कि काली है कि नहीं है आप
सारा काम जो काली वाला है वह इस पर भी कर
सकते हैं गाइस तो टेंशन नहीं लेनी है आपको
बग बाउंट की सारी चीजें आप इस पर कर सकते
हैं समझ में आ रहा होगा आपको यह जरूरी
नहीं है कि काली में ही बग होगी ना एक
लिनिक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होना चाहिए और
डेयन वेस्ड हो तो उससे बढ़िया तो कुछ है
ही नहीं तो हमने डेयन को यहां पे सेलेक्ट
कर लिया वर्जन सेलेक्ट करना है लेटेस्ट ही
करेंगे 12 जो है एंड 64 बिट वाला कर लेंगे
अब आती है यहां पे मेन चीज आपके पैसे की
बात अब यहां आपको दिख रहा होगा $2 पर मंथ
सर आपने तो बहुत सस्ता बोला था अरे है ना
यार ये प्रीमियम इंटेल डिवाइस सिलेक्टेड
है ऐसा थोड़ी ना करना है भाई ना प्रीमियम
इंटेल लेना है ना प्रीमियम हमें एमडी लेना
है हमें चाहिए रेगुलर डिस्क ज अगर आप
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं ना तो स्टार्टिंग के
लिए आपको ये प्रीमियम वाला कुछ लेना ही
नहीं है आपको एक रेगुलर डिस्क लाइए रेगुलर
जो आपका डिस्क है रेगुलर जो आपकी सर्वर है
मशीन है वो यूज कीजिए एंड सबसे पहले मैं
आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा टू गो विद $6 पर मंथ
वाली मशीन सबसे पहले जिसमें आपको
1gb रम न सीपीयू 25gb का एसएसडी स्टोरेज
मिल जाता है एंड 1000gb का आपको ट्रांसफर
मिल जाता है ऑलमोस्ट 1 टेराबाइट का
ट्रांसफर बहुत है यार बहुत है स्टार्टिंग
के लिए लिटरली बहुत है बहुत ज्यादा गुस्से
में हो थोड़ा ज्यादा पैसे खर्च करने हैं
मतलब इन द सेंस कि ज्यादा थोड़ा मतलब
एग्रेसिवली काम करना है तो यह $12 पर मंथ
पे आ जाओ एंड मैं यह कहता
हूं डॉलर टू आनर चलते
हैं 12 पर मंथ यहां पे करते हैं $1 996
होते हैं आपके ओनली 1000 से भी कम
ओबवियसली आपके एड्स में से ज्यादा आएगा जब
आप उसको एग्रेसिवली यूज करने लगेंगे ना
2gb एव सीपीयू इसमें आपको 2gb रम मिल जाता
है 50gb की एसएसडी स्टोरेज मिल जाती है 2
टेराबाइट का आपका बैंडविथ ट्रांसफर मिल
जाता है ट इ सफिशिएंट यह भी आपके
स्टार्टिंग के लिए सबसे बढ़िया है सबसे
बढ़िया आपका कौन सा स्टार्टिंग के लिए $
पर मंथ वाला जो आपका प्लान है बेस्ट प्लान
फॉर स्टार्टिंग
बेस्ट ठीक है
ग्रेट बढ़िया बढ़िया अफताब बहुत बढ़िया
चलिए गॉट इट अब ये आपने सेलेक्ट कर लिया
शो ऑल प्लांस करेंगे इनके सारे प्लांस
आपको शो हो जाएंगे हमें $ से मतलब है
दैट्ची के थ्रू ऑथेंटिकेट करना चाहते हैं
या फिर पासवर्ड के थ्रू तो दोनों में से
आप कोई सा भी सिलेक्ट कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है एसएसए की के थ्रू
कीजिएगा तो वही पमप की बन जाएगी एक पं
फाइल उसको आप आप एसएसए हान आ के थ्रू उसको
मेंशन कर सकते हैं एंड फिर वो आपका कनेक्ट
हो जाएगा फिलहाल मैं पासवर्ड क्रिएट कर
लेता हूं यहां पे सिंपल
दैट्ची आएंगे यहां और कुछ नहीं करना आपको
एडिशनल कुछ नहीं डालना है एडवांस ऑप्शंस प
अभी मूव छोड़ छोड़ते हैं एंड यहां होस्ट
नेम आ रहा है अब ये होस्ट नेम जो है ना
गाइस ये आपकी मर्जी है जो भी आप डाल लो तो
यहां पे मैं यहां पे कर देता हूं होस्ट
नेम में
डिफ्रॉक्ड
बस
दैट्ची वांट डेफॉक्स पेन टेस्ट ये मैंने
डाल दिया ये मेरा होस्ट नेम है डेफॉक्स
पॉइंट पेन
टेस्ट पेन टेस्ट है ये स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक
है है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं टैक्स डालना है
टैक्स डाल दो बग
बाउंट कुछ भी जो भी टैक्स डालना है
तुम्हें
अ बग बाउंट ये वाली टैग डाल देते हैं बग
बाउंटीज इट टैग्स हमने डाल दिया बस एक
रिकॉग्नाइजेस के लिए एंड यहां पे
प्रोजेक्ट आपका जो है वो प्रोजेक्ट जो है
वो प्रोजेक्ट आपका आ गया अब यहां पे आपको
करना है क्रिएट ड्रॉपलेट जैसे ही आप
क्रिएट ड्रॉपलेट पे जाएंगे आपका ड्रॉपलेट
क्रिएट होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगा एंड आपको
थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा थोड़ा वेट करना है ये
देखिए डे फोनिक्स पेंटेस्ट हमारा ये
क्रिएट हो रहा है ये ब्लू आप मार्क देख
रहे होंगे ये जो आपको मार्क है जैसे ही
कंप्लीट होगा आपका ड्रॉपलेट रेडी टू यूज
हो जाएगा चलिए लेट इट स्टार्ट लेट इट बी
क्रिएटेडटेड से भी अच्छा स्पीड आपको मिल
जाएगा यहां तो हमारा ड्रॉपलेट तैयार हो
चुका है आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस मिल चुकी है
भैया जब आप इस ड्रॉपलेट पे क्लिक करेंगे
तो आपको इसकी डिटेल्स मिल जाएगी यन वन
वर्चुअल सीपीयू 1gb रम 25gb डिस्क स्पेस
आईपीवी फ एड्रेस आईपीवी सि चाहते हैं तो
इनेबल कर सकते हैं प्राइवेट आईपी आपको मिल
चुकी है एंड बस
दैट्ची है इसको सीधा कॉपी कर लेना है एंड
आपके जो भी टर्मिनल है आप उस टर्मिनल का
यूज करके इसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं तो देखिए
विज में अगर आप हैं मैं आपको दोनों केसेस
बता देता
हूं विज के लिए आप डिफॉल्ट विंडोज का जो
टर्मिनल है आप इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं यह
वाला जो वि टर्मिनल आता है आप इसको भी यूज
कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे आप एसएसए कमांड
का यूज करके कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं एसएसए के
थ्रू अगर आप चाहे विंडोज में कोई और
टर्मिनल यूज करने का वो भी आप यूज कर सकते
हैं वो भी मैं आपको बताऊंगा अगर आप काली
में है लेट्स सपोज तो आप काली को भी
स्टार्ट करके काली के टर्मिनल में जाके आप
काली में भी इसको यूज कर सकते हैं वो आपकी
मर्जी है टोटली आप आपकी मर्जी ऐसा नहीं है
कि काली में आप यूज नहीं कर सकते हैं ठीक
है मैं काली को ऑन कर देता हूं यह ऑन होता
है तब तक इसम आएंगे अब विंडोज में एक और
टर्मिनल एम्युलेटर है आप उसको भी यूज कर
सकते हैं ए इसका नाम है मोबा एक्सटम यह भी
काफी बढ़िया है विंडोज के लिए विंडोज के
हिसाब से काफी अच्छा है फ्री आपका एक
एम्युलेटर है आप इस पर आएंगे यहां पे गेट
मोबा एक्सटम डाउनलोड कर लेंगे एंड इसका
पोर्टेबल वर्जन अवेलेबल है यहां पर गेट पर
क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको यहां पर दिख
जाएगा गेट मोबा एक्टम पर हमने क्लिक कर
दिया यहां पर एक फ्री वर्जन है एक पेड है
तो हमें क्या है भैया फ्री वाला यूज करना
है डाउनलोड नाउ पे क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको
एक पोर्टेबल एडिशन आएगा एक इंस्टॉल एडिशन
आएगा पोर्टेबल का मतलब डायरेक्टली क्लिक
एंड एग्जीक्यूट इंस्टॉल मतलब इंस्टॉल करके
हमने पोर्टेबल डाउनलोड करके रखा है मोबा
एक्टम इस तरीके से डाउनलोड हो जाएगा एंड
इसमें ये वाली एक्ससी फाइल होगी
दैट्ची कर लेता हूं एंड दैट्ची है मैं
यहां पे लोकल टर्मिनल स्टार्ट कर देता हूं
एंड कुछ इस तरीके से ओपन होके आ जाएगा अब
यहां पे आपको कनेक्ट करना है तो आप क्या
कर सकते हैं मैं आपको अलग-अलग अ लाइक
डिवाइस अलग-अलग तरीके से बता देता हूं
सेशंस पे आप जाएंगे यहां एसएसए लिखा हुआ
है एसएसए पे जाएंगे यहां आपको आईपी देनी
है जो आईपी हमने कॉपी की वो आईपी दे देंगे
यूजर नेम स्पेसिफाई कर दीजिए यहां पे तो
यहां पे यूजर नेम हमारा रूट होगा एंड
पोर्ट 20 22 पोर्ट आपका जो है वो आपका
होगा ठीक है एंड आप इससे कनेक्ट करेंगे
ओके करेंगे कनेक्ट आपका हो जाएगा
दैट्ची है चलिए मैं यहां पे ओके करके आपको
दिखा भी देता हूं ये आपको दिख रहा होगा
एक्सेप्ट करने का एक्सेप्ट कर लीजिए यहां
पे एंड दैट इट यहां पे अब रूट का पासवर्ड
आपसे मांगा जा रहा है रूट का पासवर्ड आपने
जो सेट किया था वही पासवर्ड है तो मैं
यहां पे रूट का पासवर्ड दे देता हूं और
एंटर करता हूं एंड डू यू वांट टू सेव
पासवर्ड नो आई डोंट वांट टू सेव पासवर्ड
एंड दैट्ची वी आर लगड इन गाइस हम यहां पर
लॉग इन हो चुके हैं इन मोबा एक्सटम एंड
आपको यहां पर दिख रहा होगा कि वी आर इन द
रूट यहां पे अब मैं यहां पे आईएफ कॉन्फिडो
आई थिंक कमांड नॉट फाउंड डीएनएस यूल्स
डालने हमें लाइक आईएफ कन्फ को इंस्टॉल
करना पड़ेगा तभी ये आपका चलेगा बट फिलहाल
के लिए मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाना चाहता हूं
हु एम आई यहां पे रूट है यहां पे आपका रूट
रूट है यहां पे एंड
इफ आई टाइप आईपी एडर तो यहां पे आपको आईपी
एड्रेस जो है वह आपको मिलके आ जाएगी एंड
अगर आप प्राइवेट आईपी की बात करते हैं तो
आपको प्राइवेट आईपी यहां पे हमारी जो मशीन
की प्राइवेट आईपी है कौन सी है 10 122 0.2
यह आपको दिख जाएगी कहां गई कहां गई कहां
गई अ 10 ये रही आपकी टीए व में 10 12202
हमारी जो प्राइवेट आईपी है वो दिख जा रही
है और यह आईपी तो आपको खैर पता ही है 157
245 100 250 वाली तो ये आपकी जो है ये
आईपी यहां पे आपको ये दिख जा रही है ठीक
है तो हम कनेक्ट हो चुके हैं हमारे मशीन
से हमारे अ बेसिकली डेयन अ ओस से ठीक है
दैट्ची डबल क्लिक करेंगे आप यहां पे
डायरेक्टली बैश आरसी का पूरा फाइल जो है
आप डायरेक्टली यहां देख पाएंगे एडिट कर
पाएंगे जो भी है यह रिमोट वाली बश बैश
आरसी है याद रखिएगा गा कंफ्यूज मत होएगा
ठीक है यहां पर आपको प्रोफाइल य दिख गया य
एसस दिख गया यहां प पेरेंट डायरेक्टरी में
जाएंगे जो कि ओबवियसली यहां पर आपको तो य
पेरेंट डायरेक्टरी आपको दिख गया जो आपके
डिजिटल ओसियन सर्वर की डायरेक्टरी है व
डायरेक्टरी आपको दिख रही है यहां पर आप
एलएस करेंगे तो यहां पर सॉरी यहां पर मैं
क्या कर देता हूं एलएस हान ए कर देता
हूं तो आपको यह फाइल्स जो है वो सारी दिख
दिख रही होंगी जो आपकी बेसिकली जो फाइल्स
है वो सारी दिख रही होंगी चलिए यहां पे
मैं रूट डायरेक्टरी में चलता हूं एंड रूट
डायरेक्टरी में जाएंगे तो ये सारी फाइल जो
यहां दिख रही है वो यहां पे भी आपको दिख
रही है तो वी आर इन टू द मशीन क्लियर वी
कैन सी वी आर इन टू द मशीन चलो मैं यहां
पे क्लियर कर देता हूं टस इट अब मान लो ये
जैसे ही आपने किया ना आप यहां आ जाओ
डिजिटल ओसियन वाले पे यहां पे आपको दिखेगा
मशीन एक्टिव है दिखेगा मशीन एक्टिव है अब
मान लो इसको मुझे बंद करना है तो मैं यहां
पर ही क्या करूंगा शट डाउन हाइन एच नाउ शट
डाउन का कमांड चला दूंगा
दैट्ची काली सेट करने का मतलब क्या होता
है जरूरी थोड़ी ना काली यूज करोगे काली को
यूज करोगे जरूरी नहीं है आपकी भाई नो नॉट
नीडेड यह देखिए ऑफ आ रहा है अब आपका ये
आपका ऑफ हो चुका है चलिए तो यह तो मोबा
एक्स्ट्रा में आपने यूज कर लिया मैं यहां
से बाहर निकल जाता हूं वी आर जस्ट गेटिंग
आउटसाइड अब मैं यहां पे काली में चलता हूं
एंड लेट्स लॉग इन काली विंडोज में तो
मैंने आपको पहले भी बताया हुआ है बट स्टिल
अब हम इसको क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे स्विच ऑन
आपको करना पड़ेगा याद रखिएगा स्विच ऑन कर
देंगे यह आपका फिर से जो है ऑन हो जाएगा
जस्ट
वेट स्विच ऑफ था मैं यहां पे मैंने इसको
ऑन किया एंड जस्ट वेट वेट
वेट चलिए ये ऑन हो गया आपका ऑन होते ही
यहां पे आपको लाइक पब्लिक आईपी आपको दिख
रही है कॉपी कर लिया हमने पब्लिक आईपी
अगेन अगेन हम यहां पे कहां पे है काली
मशीन में है काली मशीन में हम यहां पे
टर्मिनल ओपन करेंगे एंड यहां पे टर्मिनल
ओपन करके आप अपनी ये वाली ट टर्मिनल यूज
कर सकते हैं टी मक्स भी यूज कर सकते हैं
टी मक्स काफी पॉपुलर है टीक्स ले एंटर
कीजिए टीक्स का सेशन आपका जो है स्टार्ट
हो जाता है इसमें कुछ अपने फायदे हैं लाइक
अच्छी अच्छी चीज आप इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें कर
सकते हैं यहां पर ओके यह वाइड कनेक्शन
कनेक्ट क्यों नहीं है वाइड कनेक्ट कर लेते
हैं पहले
भैया लेट्स
कनेक्ट लेट इट कनेक्ट गाइस व्ट इज द इशू
चलिए फिलहाल तो यह देखते हैं यहां पर आ ग
टी मैक्स में यहां प अब देखो मैं एक चीज
करता हूं कंट्रोल बी
ल्ट एंड देन
परसेंट कंट्रोल बी ओके लेट कंट्रोल बी एंड
ल्ट एंड ये
परसेंट कंट्रोल बी शिफ्ट परसेंट इस तरीके
से आप स्प्लिट वगैरह कर पाएंगे अगर आप
चाहते हैं तो कंट्रोल बी करके एंड शिफ्ट
के साथ लाइक शिफ के साथ आप परसेंट प्रेस
कर दीजिए शिफ्ट के साथ डबल कोड प्रेस
कीजिए तो इस तरीके से आप कुछ कस्टमाइजेशन
वगैरह कर सकते हैं जैसे कंट्रोल बी एंड
एंड शिफ्ट मैंने डबल कोट किया तो यहां पे
फिर से ये बेसिकली डिवाइड हो जाता है कुछ
इस तरीके से चीजें आप कर पाएंगे इसके अंदर
में अलग-अलग टर्मिनल्स भी ओपन कर पाएंगे
एंड वहां पे अपना काम जो है वो कर पाएंगे
ठीक है स्विच कर पाएंगे एक टर्मिनल से
दूसरे टर्मिनल में काम करने के लिए तो ये
थोड़ा सा इजी भी पड़ता है इजी भी हो जाएगा
मतलब वैसे तो उसमें भी कर सकते हैं आप
नॉर्मल से टर्मिनल में बट इसके और भी
फायदे हैं टी मक्स के आप अगर टी मक्स यूज
करना चाहे तो अदर वाइज अगर आप रेगुलर चाना
चा तो रेगुलर में भी आप राइट क्लिक करके
यहां पे स्प्लिट हॉरिजॉन्टल स्प्लिट
वर्टिकली जो होता है वो आप कर सकते हैं
कोई प्रॉब्लम यहां प स्प्लिट वर्टिकली
यहां पर कर लीजिए ये एक हो जाएगा स्प्लिट
यहां पे वर्टिकली कर लीजिए एक ये हो जाएगा
चार टर्मिनल आपके वैसे हो जाएंगे बस क्लिक
कीजिए एंड आपका काम यहां प चारों में चलने
लगेगा ठीक है तो ट्स नॉट एन इशू मैं यहां
पे एग्जिट कर देता हूं
फिलहाल यहां
से ओके अब यहां पर क्या करना है आपको
कनेक्ट करना है तो कनेक्ट करने के लिए
आपको एसएसए कमांड का यूज करना है आपको
अपने मशीन से कनेक्ट करने के लिए चलिए ठीक
है अब कैसे करना है चलिए दिखा देता हूं
मैं आपको
ओके व्ट इज द इशू यहां पर नेटवर्क कनेक्ट
नहीं हुआ है मेरा वाई वाई वाई वाई
वाई यह देखिए नेटवर्क कनेक्ट नहीं हुआ है
यह नेटवर्क मेरा कनेक्टेड नहीं है वाइड
कनेक्शन इज नॉट गेटिंग कनेक्टेड सर्विस
नेटवर्क मैनेजर
टार्ट लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग अदर वाइज
हम वीएम वेर का एक बार नेटवर्क एडिटर चेक
कर लेते हैं कुछ प्रॉब्लम है
क्या चेंज सेटिंग्स
यस ओके ओके वम ब्रिज है आपके वायरलेस पे
एंड ओके ठीक है एवरीथिंग इज फाइन कंपलीटली
फाइन कोई बात नहीं चलिए यह आपका मैं एक
बार अभी के लिए फिलहाल नेटवर्क नेटवर्क
कॉन्फिन थोड़ा सा चेंज कर देता हूं ताकि
जल्दी से हमारा काम हो जाए यहां पर मैं
नेट करता हूं एक
बार लेट्स
वेट
अ ओके कनेक्टेड एंड आई आई हैफ
कॉन्फिन करके देख लेते हैं पि google.com
एंड इट्स पिंग वेरी वेरी गुड चलिए यह आपका
काम हो गया अब आपको कनेक्ट करना है आपके
ड्रॉपलेट से आपके मशीन से आपके चलिए मशीन
से कैसे कनेक्ट करेंगे भैया यहां पे आपकी
आईपी एड्रेस कॉपी कर लिया यहां पे आया और
यहां पे एसएसए कमांड डाला उसके बाद रूट
यूजर नेम आप का रहेगा एंड रूट रेट एंड जो
आपका यूजर जो आपका आईपी है वो डाल दिया
दैट्ची पासवर्ड मांगेगा जो पासवर्ड भैया
सेट किया था वो पासवर्ड यहां डाल देंगे और
एंटर कर देंगे एंड वी आर लगड इन इनटू रूट
रे डिक्स पेन टेस्ट बॉक्स ये एक डेयन
लिनिक्स है एंड ओबवियसली यू आर इनसाइड दैट
मशीन आप अपने मशीन के अंदर हो अब यहां पे
गाइस आप अपना वह सारा काम कर सकते हैं जो
आप करना चाहते हैं जो आप करना चाहते हैं
सारे वो चीजें कर सकते हैं अब यह आपका डेन
ओस है अब यहां पर एप्ट अपडेट कर लीजिए ठीक
है एप्ट अपडेट किया आपका अपडेट हो चुका
एप्ट अपग्रेड कर
लीजिए जो भी आपको कमांड चलाने हैं एप्ट
अपग्रेड देन यह
एप्ट अपग्रेड आपका हो चुका यह मशीन आपका
देख सकते स्पीड देखिए कितनी शानदार स्पीड
आ रही है भाई हो गया
अपग्रेड 14 एबी पर सेकंड देख रहे हो आप 14
एबी पर सेकंड का यहां प स्पीड अभी फिलहाल
आपको दे रहा है य बहुत बहुत ज्यादा
यार हमेशा नहीं आता है कभी-कभी इशू आता है
कोई बात नहीं वो ठीक हो जाएगा फिर ठीक है
ब्रिज वाली कोई दिक्कत नहीं है राइट यस
टर्मिनेटर यूज कर सकते हैं टी मक्स यूज कर
सकते हैं डिफॉल्ट यूज कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है टी मक्स वगैरह में थोड़ा
बैकग्राउंड लाइक बैकग्राउंड में भी आपका
काम होता रहता है जहां से आपने छोड़ा है
वहीं से स्टार्ट हो जाएगा कुछ ये फीचर्स
आपको प्रोवाइड होते हैं टीम में काफी
अच्छा है तो काफी लोग यूज करते हैं आप भी
उसको यूज कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है टीक्स को आप इंटीग्रेट भी कर सकते हैं
अपने ज लाइक अपने शेल के साथ तो चलिए लेट
इट फिनिश लेट इट फिनिश द प्रोग्रेस एंड
हमारा अपग्रेड ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका है तो आप
देख सकते हैं यहां
पे तो यहां पर तो हमने काली वाले टर्मिनल
में यह चीज कर दी है
राइट अब यहां देखो जैसे बहुत लोगों का
दिक्कत बहुत लोगों के साथ क्या प्रॉब्लम
है बहुत लोग क्या
करेंगे
बहुत लोगों को लग रहा है कि काली कहा गया
अरे भैया काली कुछ नहीं है आपको टूल सेटप
करने हैं आपके वीपीएस पे देन आपको यूज
करना है ठीक है समझ में आया
चलो दिखा देता हूं मैं
[संगीत]
आपको ये आपका हो गया प्रोसेस
कंप्लीट ठीक है यह डन अब य यहां पे यहां
पे गाइस अब क्या करना है जैसे आपको एलएस
करते हैं सॉरी एलएस आप करेंगे यहां पे कुछ
नहीं है यहां पे कुछ भी आपको नहीं पता है
डब् एच ओ हु एम आई करेंगे तो रूट है
पीडब्ल्यूडी करेंगे तो होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
इसमें हिस्ट्रीज होती है अब मान लो यहां
पे तुम क्या करोगे भैया यहां पे तुम एक
फोल्डर बना
दोगे क्या करोगे एक फोल्डर बना दोगे क्या
फोल्डर बना दोगे फोल्डर का नाम कुछ भी दे
सकते हो व्हाट एवर यू वांट टू गिव यू कैन
गिव जैसे सीडी एंड मेरा यहां करा बग
बाउंटीज ये एक फोल्डर बना देंगे सीडी
क्यों दिया भाई एम केडीआर देंगे ना यार
क्या यार तुम भी एमकेडी आई आर बग बाउंट
टूल्स एंटर किया एलएस किया बग बाउंट टूल्स
आ गई सीडी बग बाउटी टूल्स में चले जाएंगे
एंड
दैट्ची बाउंट टूल्स का जो भी टूल्स आपको
चाहिए वो टूल्स यहां डालेंगे हम उस टूल को
इंस्टॉल करेंगे व्हाट एवर व्हाट एवर व्हाट
एवर ठीक है बस
दैट्ची में विंडोज में भी करना है तुम्हें
तुम सेम चीज विंडोज में करो यार कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है तुम्हें इससे थोड़ी ना
मतलब है तो यहां एग्जिट कर दो कनेक्शन टू
डैश क्लोज्ड काली का काम खत्म काली को कर
दिया मिनिमाइज चलिए विंडो ये कॉपी पब्लिक
आईपी कॉपी कर ली विंडोज वाली टर्मिनल ओपन
कर ली यहां पे कर लेते हैं ये सीएलएस यहां
पे नाम कर देते हैं सब्सक्राइब डि फ्रक्स
एकेडमी यहां हमने नाम कर दिया यहां हमने
कलर चूज कर ली एक बढ़िया सा कलर चूज कर
लिया एंड यहां पे मैंने इसको मैक्सिमाइज
कर दिया यहां थोड़ा सा इसको बड़ा कर देते
हैं एंड यहां पे एसएस एच कर देते हैं यहां
रूट कर देते हैं एड रेट कर देते हैं एंड
यहां पर अपनी आईपी डाल देते हैं फिर से
कनेक्ट कर देते हैं यस करके एंड ट्स इट
पासवर्ड जो हमने डाला था वह पासवर्ड हमने
किया एंड हमने विंडोज के टर्मिनल से लॉगइन
कर लिया नाउ वी आर इन टू द विंडोज याय
एलएस करोगे तो बग बाउंट टूल जो आपने वहां
काली में बनाई थी वो यहां पे भी आ गई है
यानी वो मशीन प काम हो रही है आपके सब कुछ
क्या हो रहा है आपके मशीन पे इस मशीन में
जो भी आप काम करोगे वह तब तक रहेगा जब तक
आप इस मशीन को मैं आपको दिखाता हूं जब आप
इस मशीन पर
जाएंगे जब आप मैक में भी कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं जब आप मशीन पे
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आप आएंगे तो यहां ऑप्शन
पे आएंगे तो डिस्ट्रॉय का एक ऑप्शन है
डिस्ट्रॉय करेंगे तभी ये आपका हर एक चीज
डेटा वाटा डिलीट करेगा अदर वाइज आपको बंद
करना है तो या तो आप शट डाउन हान एच नाउ
कमांड चला दीजिए यहां से ऑफ कर दीजिए
टेंपररी ये ऑफ हो जाएगा एंड आपका जो डाटा
है वो सेव्ड ही रहेगा ठीक है समझ गए अब
यहां पे बगवा टूल्स फोल्डर बन चुकी है सब
कुछ क्लियर है एवरीथिंग इज गुड अब आपको
यहां पे सीडी बग बाउटी टूल्स में जाना है
यहां पे और एंटर कर देना है एंड यहां पे
कुछ भी नहीं है खाली है एंड अब हम यहां पे
सेटअप कर सकते हैं टूल्स का टूल्स का
सेटअप करने का मतलब क्या है भाई देखो मैं
आपको एक चीज बताता हूं टूल्स का सेटअप
करने का मतलब क्या है वो आपको समझाता
हूं जब आप इंटरनेट प चलेंगे यहां पे तो
यहां पे बीबी एचटी गिट हब मैं ये आपको
दिखा देता हूं ही दिस टूल स्क्रिप्ट है ये
एक बाय नहम सेक एंड ये क्या आ रहा है
रिमाइंड मी टुमारो नेमसेक का यह इनका टूल
है आप इस रिपोजिटरी प आएंगे हालांकि यह
बहुत लाइक फव इयर्स एगो का यहां पर अपडेट
आपको दिख रहा है बट आपको इसमें बहुत काम
की चीजें मिल जाएंगी तो बेसिकली क्या है
देखो यहां
पे यह बग बाउंट हंटिंग टूल्स इज अ
स्क्रिप्ट टू इंस्टॉल द मोस्ट पॉपुलर
टूल्स यूज्ड वाइल लुकिंग फॉर वल एबिलिटीज
फॉर अ बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम काली में क्या
होता है कि काली को जब आप यूज करते हैं तो
बहुत सारे टूल्स ऑटोमेटिक इंस्टॉल्ड आते
हैं काली में या उसके रोलिंग रिपोजिटरी जो
है उसके अंदर आपको मिल जाएंगे एप्ट
इंस्टॉल किया काम हो गया बट जब आप u2 या
कोई और डेयन या कोई भी और डेस्ट यूज कर
रहे हैं तो जहां पे आपको ये चीज पहले से
नहीं मिले तो आपको मैनुअली वो चीज इंस्टॉल
करनी पड़ेगी एंड वो ज्यादा बेटर अप्रोच
होता है याद रखिएगा बहुत ज्यादा बेटर चीज
होती है वो मैनुअली जब आप करते हैं
इंस्टॉल तो यहां पे आपको वो सारे टूल्स
मिल जाते हैं जो आपको जैसे टूल्स में ये
कौन से डीर सर जेस पास नॉक पाइल ए3 ये
मतलब सारे आपको टूल्स इंस्टॉल करने को मिल
जाते हैं सिंपली आप आपको इस रिपोजिटरी को
क्लोन करना है सीडी करना है परमिशन देनी
है एंड एग्जीक्यूट कर देना है अब देखो
यहां पे सिंपली गिट क्लोन करोगे यहां पे
गिट क्लोन गिट क्लोन काम करेगा क्या एक
बार देख लो यहां पे गिट कमांड काम करेगा
गिट लिखा गिट नॉट फाउंड तो क्या करना है
भैया एप्ट इंस्टॉल
गिट क्या करना है गिट को इंस्टॉल करना
पड़ेगा गिट को बिना इंस्टॉल किए नहीं कर
पाओगे आप तो हमने क्या किया गिट को
इंस्टॉल किया अब ये गिट आपका इंस्टॉल हो
चुका है अब आप गिट क्लोन करोगे तो आपका
गिट काम करेगा यानी हर एक चीज आप एकदम
स्क्रैच से करोगे तो आपको फील भी आएगा अब
यहां पे एप्ट इंस्टॉल गो गो लैंग करके एक
बार देखते हैं एंड ये गो लैंग्वेज को
इंस्टॉल कर देगा गो लैंग यानी कि गो को
इंस्टॉल कर देगा आपके मशीन पे तो गो वाली
जो भी बाइनरीज होंगी जो भी टूल्स गो पे चल
रहे हैं वो टूल्स बेसिकली आप यहां पे फिर
चला पाएंगे एंड आप उसको यूज कर पाएंगे गो
का पाथ सेट कर दीजिएगा एक्सपोर्ट पाथ करके
जो गो वाला है बस हो गया आपका काम हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो चलिए यह आपका यहां पे हो
रहा है वो पाथ सेट करने का भी मैंने आपको
बताया
था ओके तो ये वाली टूल कर दए या फिर यहां
पे बहुत सारे हैं वीपीएस बग
बाउंटीज ऐसे मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं जैसे
एक यह भी है यह भी है आप ये दोनों कोई सा
भी कर सकते हैं जैसे आप इस पे आए यहां पे
तो ये 3 साल पहले एंड जो इसका फाइव मंथ्स
पहले भी अपडेट है कुछ यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट
दैट ऑटोमेट द इंस्टॉलेशन ऑफ मेन टूल्स
यूज्ड फॉर वेब एप्लीकेशन पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग एंड बग बाउंट तो ये भी है अ लाइक
अ आपको स्क्रिप्ट मिल रही है यहां पे तो
आप ये भी चला सकते हैं ये भी आप यूज़ कर
सकते हैं कौन-कौन से टूल्स हैं ये देख
लीजिए नेटवर्क स्कैनर में ए मैप मास स्कैन
नाबू एंड सब डोमेन इमेशन में आपको ये सारे
टूल्स आपको मिल जाएंगे सब डोमेन टेकओवर के
लिए ये मिल जाएगा वेब फजर के लिए ये आपको
मिल जाता है वर्डलिस्ट में आपको ये मिल
जाती है स्कैनर जो सीएमएस के हैं ये मिल
जाते हैं स्ल के लिए ये है नमरे
जावास्क्रिप्ट के लिए ये है लिंक फाइंडर
विजुअल रिकॉर्न सारी चीजें आपको मिल जाती
है या फिर आप ये वाला भी यूज कर सकते हैं
दिस टूल ठीक है ये वाला आप यूज कर लीजिए
कोई सा जो भी आप मतलब आप चाहते हैं तो ये
वाला यूज कर लीजिए या तो आप ये वाला भी
यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है ये भी आपको लाइक
तीन दो साल पहले का ऐसा कुछ है यहां पे भी
आपको टूल्स की लिस्ट जो है यहां पे आपको
मिल जाएगी ये सारे एस एसेट फेंडर कट ये
सारे टूल्स आपको यहां पे इसमें मिल जाते
हैं बहुत सारे टूल्स हैं इसमें भी तो ये
सबसे बेटर मुझे लगा बढ़िया लगा ये तो
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है आपको लाइक यहां
से गिट क्लोन कर लेना है देख देख लीजिए
इंस्टॉलेशन य दे रखा होगा यहां पे नीचे आ
जाइए यहां नीचे आ जाते इंस्टॉलेशन का यह
रहा ओके ए गेट अपडेट एप्ट अपग्रेड करना है
ट्स वई गिट को इंस्टॉल कर लेना है खत्म बस
ट्स इट इतना ही करना था टम टम डायरेक्टरी
में कह रहे हैं और गिट क्लोन को यहां पे
यह बोल रहे है कि गिट क्लोन वहां प कीजिए
एंड देन आप जाके इंस्टलर को चला दीजिए तो
हमने जैसे यहां पर क्या
किया कॉपी कर
लिया अब हम अपने मशीन पे चलते हैं यहां पे
हम बग बाउंट टूल्स में ऑलरेडी है यहां पे
हम यहां पे करते हैं गिट क्लोन एंड हमने
जो कॉपी किया था यह कर दिया वेब हैकिंग
टूल्स वाली एंड हमने एंटर कर दिया अब ये
इसकी डायरेक्टरी कॉपी हो जाएगी बन जाएगी
सीडी एलएस करोगे आपको दिखेगा यहां पे वेब
हैप टूल्स सीडी वेब हैक टूल्स आगे हम यहां
पे इसके अंदर एलएस करेंगे यहां पे एलएस
करेंगे तो आपको एक इंस्टॉल ड एएच फाइल
मिलेगी इसको परमिशन दे देंगे सी मोड + x
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन दे रहे हैं बेसिकली
यहां पे तो यहां पे हमने एग्जीक्यूट का
परमिशन दे दिया जैसे एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन
दिया नाउ वी आर रेडी टू एग्जीक्यूट इट
डॉलर ड एच कर देंगे एंटर कर देंगे एंड अब
जो है देखो यहां पे पैकेज रिक्वायर्ड
इंस्टॉलेशन इन प्रोग्रेस इंस्टॉलेशन डज
गोल एनवायरमेंट इंस्टॉलेशन इन प्रोग्रेस
तो गोलंग का भी ये इंस्टॉलेशन करके
एनवायरमेंट सेट भी कर देंगे ये मेरे ख्याल
से सब फाइंडर इंस्टॉलेशन इन प्रोग्रेस सब
फाइंडर को ही इंस्टॉल कर रहे हैं एंड ये
सारा जो जो टूल्स हैं वो सारे टूल्स जो है
ये इंस्टॉल करेंगे जो बग बाउंट में आपके
यूजफुल जनरली होते हैं इनके अलावा भी कोई
टूल आप यूज करने जा रहे हैं तो आप उसको
अलग से इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है बहुत बहुत इजी है ठीक है तो ये
अभी सब फाइंडर इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है ठीक
है उसके बाद बाकी टूल जितने भी टूल्स
लिस्ट में सब इंस्टॉल होगी ठीक ओके गॉट
इट कार्ड नहीं है तो कुछ नहीं हो सकता
ब्रदर सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी अब हैकर वाली
फीलिंग आएगी आपको अभी देख लो हैकर वाली
फीलिंग है ना आपको तभी तो हैकर वाली
फीलिंग आती है रेड ग्रीन अ ब्लैक ये सब हो
जाता है
तो देखो इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है इंस्टॉलेशन
इज डन इंस्टॉलेशन डन सारे इंस्टॉलेशन हो
रहे हैं
आपके यह आपके मशीन पे हो रही है रिमोट
मशीन पे याद रखिएगा ये आपके लोकल सिस्टम
पे या विंडोज पे नहीं हो रहा ये
इंस्टॉलेशन ये सारा कुछ आपके रिमोट मशीन
पे यानी कि आपके इस डिजिटल ओसियन के इस
डेवियन जो आपकी मशीन चल रही है ना जो आपकी
ड्रॉपलेट चल रही है ये वाली ड्रॉपलेट इसके
अंदर हो रही है सारी चीजें ठीक है एक 25gb
जो डिस्क स्टोरेज स्पेस है आप इस पर क्लिक
करेंगे यहां पे तो यहां पर आप क्लिक
करेंगे तो इसकी पूरी ग्राफ देख पाएंगे
देखो जैसे यहां पे बैंडविथ यूज करना जैसे
ही बढ़ गया हमारा बैंडविथ ये देखो बैंडविथ
यूज बढ़ा सीपीय यूज भी बढ़ा डिस्क यूज भी
बढ़ा ये देख रहे हो यहां पे अब यहां पे
तुम आ जाओ वॉल्यूम्स पे आ जाओ एक बार
लेट्स कम टू वॉल्यूम्स अच्छा अभी
वॉल्यूम्स हमने ऐड ही नहीं किया ना वो ठीक
है यहां पे रिसाज प आ जाते हैं एक बार कुछ
रि साइज की जरूरत तो अभी शायद नहीं पड़ेगी
यहां पे आ जाते हैं यहां पे कोई ऐसा कुछ
है नहीं अभी साइज की जरूरत अभी तो हमारा
बहुत बहुत साइज है यार बहुत अभी ब यूज केस
अभी बचा हुआ है अभी तो 25gb 25gb का स्पेस
है काफी है 25gb चलाने के लिए तो सारी चीज
देख सकते हैं यहां पे यहां पे आपकी
इंस्टॉलेशन ये हो रही है मास डीएनएस वगैरह
जो है वो भी इंस्टॉल हो रहा
है टमक्स पे क्या-क्या करोगे भैया
क्या-क्या करोगे टमक्स पे यार टमक्स से
बाहर निकलो भाई प्लीज रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं
आपसे प्लीज गेट आउट ऑफ द टमक्स टमक्स वाली
यार कीड़ा जो है ना यार वो उससे बाहर निकल
जाओ यार रिक्वेस्ट है मेरी कितना कब तक
चलोगे टा मक्स
प अच्छा जी यूनिक जी तो यूनिक जी बोल रहे
हैं सर आप बग बाउंट सिखा रहे हैं क्लाउड
सेटअप करने की आप वीडियो अपलोड कर सकते
हैं अब आपके अकॉर्डिंग तो करेंगे नहीं
यूनिक जी है ना अपने अकॉर्डिंग ही करेंगे
अगर आपको नहीं सीखना है तो आप बिल्कुल मोर
देन वेलकम है यहां से जाने के लिए कोई
टेंशन नहीं है मुझे सिखाना है जिसको सीखना
है वो सीखेंगे ही एंड मुझे सिखाना है मैं
सिखा के रहूंगा मैंने बताया था ना प्रो बग
बाउंट हंटर वो मैंने बोल दिया है तो मैं
वो चीज करके रहूंगा आप जैसे कुछ लोग आएंगे
एंड थोड़ी कुछ फालतू बोल के चले जाएंगे
उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ने वाला है मुझे
पता है आप लोगों को बहुत ज्यादा कुछ लोगों
को ऐसी दिक्कत हो रही है ना इस बगवां
सीरीज से क्योंकि फ्री में आ रही है सीरीज
बिल्कुल फ्री में बहुत लोगों के धंदे बंद
हो रहे हैं बहुत लोगों का प्रॉब्लम हो रहा
है बहुत लोगों को तो भाई बग बाउटी की
कोर्स चलती है उनका भी बैंड ब रहा है जहां
तक मुझे पता चला तो भाई कोई फायदा नहीं है
यार आप सीखते रहो मस्ती में एकदम बिंदास
सीखते रहो ठीक
है ओके चलिए यहां पे इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है
आपकी प्योर डीएनएस डीएनएस एक्स मास डीएनए
क्रोबैट ए मैस गट लब सब डोमस गट हब सब
डोमस फाइंड डोमस सब फाइंडर एसेट फाइंडर
गोलंग आपका हो चुका अब यहां पे एक्वाटोन
हो रहा है एचटीटी प्रो यहां पे आपकी
इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है अब यहां एटीडी पी
एक्स भी हो चुका है यहां प एन मैप की
इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है सारे टूल्स इंस्टॉल
करेगा
भैया गौरव नहीं पता मुझे यार मुझे नाम
नहीं याद है मुझे इतना याद नहीं रहता
यार धन्यवाद शैलेश
धन्यवाद
ओके इसम आप नाबू सारी इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही
है होने देते हैं इसको पहले
तो लेट इट
बी लेट इट बी लेट इट
बी
धन्यवाद सपोर्ट डि
फ्रक्स ठीक है हैक कल
गो
स्पाइडर
ओके यह सही यार हैग चालू कर दिया भाई
ने हां जी हां जी हां जी बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
तो हमने एक चीज मैं आपको वो कर देता हूं
ने आपको क्या बताया एक एडब्ल्यू का
अल्टरनेटिव आपको
बताया आपको एडब्ल्यू का अल्टरनेटिव बताया
डिजिटल
ओसन ठीक है टी मक्स के बारे में बताया आप
यूज कर सकते हैं मोबा एक्सटम के बारे में
बताया आप इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है
एंड हमने क्या किया ड्रॉपलेट्स को चालू
किया ड्रॉपलेट क्रिएट किया ड्रॉपलेट्स को
क्रिएट किया एंड हमने उसको एसएसए के थ्रू
एक्सेस किया ठीक है किसको एक्सेस किया
भैया डेवियन को एक्सेस किया ठीक
है थैंक यू डीजे भाई तुम सुपर चैट तुमने
सुपर चैट का वो खोल रखा है क्या सुपर चैट
क्यों करते हो यार कोई फायदा मत करो सुपर
चैट कोई जरूरत नहीं है भाई जो सुपर चैट
तुम कर रहे हो मुझे ₹ का डीजे आई वुड लाइक
टू रिक्वेस्ट एक रिक्वेस्ट है आपसे कि
आपने अभी तक मुझे लगता है 300 400 सुपर चट
कर दिए अभी तक जहां तक मुझे याद है आई
डोंट नो एजेक्ट फिगर आप जो भी करना आगे भी
चाहते है ना आप प्लीज वो 400 500 000 जो
भी करेंगे या करना चाहते थे उनको लीजिए
एंड किसी ऐसे पर्सन को उसको उसकी कोई चीज
खरीद के आप प्रोवाइड कीजिए जो उसकी जरूरत
हो जिसको लाइक कोई पुअर हो कोई कहीं पे हो
कहीं ऐसे या विंटर है आप उसमें कि किसी को
कुछ हेल्प कीजिए मेरे वाली जो है हेल्प
मेरी वाली जो कंट्रीब्यूशन जो आप कर रहे
हो वो आप उसको जाके कर दीजिए ठीक है या
किसी को कुछ खिलाइए दैट वुड बी मोर बेटर
है
ना
चलिए
अनीश पात्रा सर आप ऐसी चीजें बनाते रहो सर
फुल सपोर्ट है हमारा आपको कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बहुत अच्छा और क्वा ओके थैंक यू थैंक
यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
अनीश ऐसी टूल्स कैसे बनाओगे बैश सीखो
पाइथन सीखो स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज जो भी
है आप सीख के बना सकते हो ओबवियसली यह टूल
जो है आपकी यह बैच में ही तो बनी है भाई
सेल स् सेल स्क्रिप्टिंग हुई है इस टूल
में सेल स्क्रिप्टिंग पर बनी हुई टूल है
ये और कुछ भी नहीं है कोड बस ट्स इट तो
यहां पर आपकी इंस्टॉलेशन यह सारी
इंस्टॉलेशन यह देख रहे हो आप सारी
इंस्टॉलेशन चल रही है आपकी य सारी टूल्स
जो है व आपकी इंस्टॉल हो रहे हैं चलिए
यहां पर एक काम करता हूं मैं चलता हूं
डिजिटल ओसन पे मैं अभी रीलोड करता
हूं एंड
या सीब रम ठीक है
बढ़िया य हिस्ट्री आप यहां से देख सकते
हैं बेसिकली य तो हरा प्रोजेक्ट है चलो तो
यहां पर इंस्टॉलेशन जब हो जाएगी देखो जैसे
एल व बिलिटी स्कैनर अभी हो रही है जैसे इस
टूल में जो जो चीज होंगी वह सारी होंगी
ठीक है तो हमने अभी क्या किया यह वाला यूज
किया व बिलिटी स्कैनर हमारा हो रहा है व
बिलिटी स्कैनर यह वाला हमारा कौन सा चल
रहा है अभी वलन बिलिटी स्कैनर कहां गया
कहां गया कहां गया यह वाला चल रहा है इसके
बाद बस थोड़े से ही टूल
वटी स्कनर के बाद सीएमएस वड लिस्ट एंड गिट
हंटिंग सेंसिटिव एंड यूजफुल टूल्स यह सारे
जो है यह बचे हुए हैं य जो ये भी जो है
आपके हो जाएंगे यहां पर उसके बाद आप गुड
टू गो है यू कैन स्टार्ट द हंटिंग प्रोसेस
ठीक है आप सारे टूल्स को यूज कर पाएंगे
बहुत ही आसानी से यूज कर पाएंगे कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं
होगी न्यूक्लि का भी यहां पर न्यूक्लि भी
हो रहा है आपका आपको दिख रहा होगा तो
न्यूक्लि इ आल्सो
देयर न्यूक्लि इज आल्सो देयर अच्छा ये
कॉपी हो गया
सॉरी हां एक काम चल चलिए एक काम और करते
हैं इसको हम चलने देते हैं इसको हम चलने
देते हैं नया टैब ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए एंड लेट्स डू वन थिंग एसएसए
करते हैं एंड सेम हम अपने मशीन पे एक नए
टैब में एक एसस करते हैं एक यहां पर हमने
एच किया एंड लेट्स वेट पासवर्ड दे देते
हैं
अ पासवर्ड दे दिया एंड हमने यहां पे लॉग
इन कर लिया अब हमने यहां पे देखो यहां
पे कौन सी टूल इंस्टॉल की है जैसे हमने
कोई से भी एक टूल उठा लेते हैं जैसे हमने
इंस्टॉल किया एफएफ यूएफ सो लेट्स ट्राई
एफएफ यूएफ यह देखिए एफएफ यूएफ किया एंटर
किया एंड एफएफ यूएफ की आपकी हेल्प फाइल आ
गई एंड यू कैन नाउ
लिटरली
लाइक यूज एफएफ
यफ समझ में आ रहा है आप एफएफ यूएफ को आप
लिटरली यूज कर सकते हो भैया चलाना है चला
दो एफएफ यूएफ को इंस्टॉल हो चुकी है कोई
टेंशन नहीं है भाई ये चल गया अब जैसे मान
लो कहां गया ए मैस भी है ना ए मैस का भी
इंस्टॉलेशन हुआ है चलिए ए मैस को भी देख
लेते हैं क्या दिक्कत आ रही है एमस को
न्यू टब में करया मैंने एमस आजा भाई ओके
व्हाट इज द इशू एस का क्या क्या दिक्कत हो
गया सीडी बग बाउटी टूल्स एलएस सीडी वेब
हैकिंग टूल्स
एलस करते हैं यहां
पे ठीक
है ओके अब हम यहां पे यहां पे इंस्टॉल एसज
जो है ना इसको हम एक बार कैट कर लेते हैं
इंस्टॉल एस को एक बार देख लेते हैं इसके
अंदर क्या-क्या चीजें हैं मैं यहां प ऊपर
चलता हूं यहां पे इस कोड को देखता हूं
यहां पे ओके गो डायरेक्टरी में एमस को
इंस्टॉल किया गया है शायद गो के अंदर ओके
ओके ओके ओके ओके चलिए यह रही चक स्क्र रूट
प्रिविलेजेस ठीक है ठीक है यहां पे बैनर
ठीक है ओके बैनर आ गया यहां पे अप गेट
अपडेट अपग्रेड
ओके एंड एगेट इंस्टॉल ठीक है आई थिंक एमएस
इज आई थिंक गो के साथ है ये कंफिट चलिए
देख लेते हैं एक बार गो वाले डायरेक्टरी
में जाके गो का पाथ सेट है क्या अ
सीडी एंड यहां एलएस करते हैं यहां पे एलएस
में यस गो आ चुका है आपका सीडी गो पे चलते
हैं एलएस करते हैं गो के अंदर चलके एंड
यहां पे सीडी बिन में चले जाते हैं गो
वाले में एलएस कर देते हैं यहां पे एंड
बिन में जाएंगे तो ये सारे टूल्स आपको मिल
जाएंगे एंड यहां पे आपको कुछ मिलना चाहिए
एमएस इज नॉट हियर कोई बात नहीं कौन सी है
एफएफ यूएफ है तो गो तो पाथ सेट हो चुका है
गो का पाथ सेट हो चुका है गाइ आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे मैं एलएस करता हूं एलएस हान
है तभी एग्जीक्यूट हुआ डायरेक्ट अब मैं
यहां पे चलता हूं डॉट प्रोफाइल में कैट
डॉट प्राइल कर लेते हैं एंड यहां देखिए गो
का पाथ सेट है क्या नहीं बैश आरसी में है
क्या ठीक है बैश आरसी चलते हैं बैश आरसी
में सेटअप होगा बैश आरसी सी एंड एंटर करते
हैं एंड य ये देखिए एक्सपोर्ट पाथ यूजर
यूएसआर लोकल एस बन यूएसआर लोकल एबीन एंड
यहां पे आप देख लीजिए यूएसआर लोकल गो बिन
तो आपका पाथ सेट हो चुका है
ये अ कहां गया कहां गया यस तो आपका पाथ
सेट हो चुका है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
दैट्ची जिएगा
सीडी गो एलएस कीजिएगा यहां पे सीडी बिन
में जाइएगा आपको गो वाले सारे टूल्स दिख
जाएंगे जो यहां पे इंस्टॉल हुए हैं जैसे
एसेट फाइंडर हो गया डल फॉक्स एए यूएफ आ
गया ग गिट अप सा फाइंडर गो बस्टर हैक रोलर
के एकस एसडी प्रोब ये प्योर डीएनए सब सब
जेएस कबड ये सारे आपके गो वाले टूल्स हैं
जैसे एसेट फाइंडर आपको करना है डायरेक्ट
एसएस फाइंडर कीजिए हान h कीजिए आपको एसएस
फाइंडर दिख जाएगा सब यहां पे सब डोमस
डालने हैं एंड
दैट्ची प्योर डीएनएस करना है आपको प्योर
डीएनएस आप यूज कीजिए प्योर डीएनएस जो है
इसकी फाइल आपकी यहां पे आ जाएगी ठीक है बट
एमएस
[संगीत]
का इंस्टॉलेशन देख लेते हैं एमएस इज नॉट अ
एमएस की कुछ इश्यूज होंगे बट इसका ना हम
एक बार काम करते हैं एक बार एमएस की इसकी
कोड को देख लेते हैं चलिए हर चीज को ना
समझने आना चाहिए हर चीज को कैसे क्या किस
तरीके से ये काम कर रही है एक बार वेब
हैकिंग वाली इस स्क्रिप्ट में चलते हैं
एंड यहां पे कंट्रोल एफ करके ए मैस सर्च
कर लेते हैं ए मैस तो यह रही ए मैस यहां
पे ओके ए मैस का यहां पर इको सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन एस इंस्टॉलेशन इन प्रोग्रेस
कहां पर है भैया यह सीडी टेम ओके है टप
डायरेक्टरी बना दिया क्या टेंप में डब्लू
गेट एमस कर दिया यहां पे एंड डेव नल ठीक
है क्लूड कर दिया एंड यहां पर एस की
इंस्टॉलेशन
एमएस यूजर लोकल बिन यूएसआर लोकल बिन में
एमएस को डाल दिया एमएस को यूएसआर लोकल बिन
में डाल दिया
है ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है भाई तो यूस
लोकल बिन तो पाथ सेट है तो हमारा एमस तो
एग्जीक्यूट होना चाहिए ना टेंप डायरेक्टरी
बना दि है क्या इन्होंने
सीडी बग बाउंट टूल्स एलएस टेंप डायरेक्टरी
बनी है क्या वेब हैकिंग टूल्स एल
एस
ठीक
है नथिंग सीडी यहां पे कोई टेंप
डायरेक्टरी स्लैश के अंदर है ना तो सीडी
स्लैश करते हैं और इसमें चलते हैं स्लैश
के अंदर टेंप था तो यहां एलएस में टेंप
होगी शायद यहां टीएमपी बनी है सीडी टीएमपी
इसके अंदर चलते हैं अरे हां यहां पे आपकी
टेंप डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में यहां पे कहां
आया है एमएस लिनिक्स जो फाइल है य यहां पे
डली हुई है इन्होंने यहां डाला हुआ है और
इसको यूएसआर लोकल बिन में डाला है तो सीडी
यस आर लोकल एंड बिन इसमें चल देते हैं एलस
करते यहां एमस आपको दिख जाना चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल से वेर इज
एस इने एस को इंस्टॉल ही नहीं किया सही से
यार या एस इ नॉट इंस्टॉल करेक्टली ट्स वा
इट्स नॉट यर कोई बात ही नहीं है भैया यह
क्या बात हो गई तो हमें क्या करना है हमें
देखना है किस का भैया ममस का इन्होने
खिचड़ी क्यों बना दिया हा डाउनलोड कहां पर
किया आपको कोड रीड करने आना चाहिए
टेंप में किया ठीक है वह मिल गया हमें एस
लिनिक्स एमडी 6 जिप ठीक है जिप ठीक है एस
लिनिक्स एमडी ठीक है भैया तो एमस को यहां
पर मूव तो किया है यूएसआर लोकल बिन में यह
मूवी नहीं हुआ है इसका मतलब है यूएसआर
लोकल बिन में इन्होंने एमएस की बाइनरी को
मूव किया है बट यूएसआर लोकल बिन में हम है
हमें तो कहीं एमस नहीं दिख रहा दिख रहा है
क्या आप लोगों को भाई कहीं नहीं दिख रहा
मुझे एमस सर्च मारो भाई कहीं नहीं है
इन्होने धोखा किया हमारे साथ यह धोखा हुआ
है ना धोखा टेम डायरेक्टरी में है ना
इन्होंने वो नहीं किया अब यह पाथ तो है तो
ये काम करते हैं ना भाई क्या दिक्कत है
सीडी टीएमपी चलते हैं टेम डायरेक्टरी
में टूल ने तो नहीं किया हमारे साथ यह चीज
एमएस को इंस्टॉल कर दिया य ऊपर में देखो
ये एमस इंस्टॉल का ऑप्शन तो दे दिया है
मतलब यह दे दिया कि एमस इंस्टॉल
सक्सेसफुली नहीं भी हुआ त भी कर दे रहे
क्या सक्सेसफुली ह यार एफफ यूफ एफफ यूफ
एफफ यूफ वेर इ एम
एस
ए सुपर इंस्टॉल हुआ तो था ना
हमारे लेटस फाइन व तो हम कर लेंगे मैनुअली
लेकिन पहले मैं देख रहा हूं करा क्यों
नहीं एस इंस्टॉलेशन इ डन इसका मतलब ने झूट
मट का इंस्टॉल कर दिया क्या ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं हम य से क्या करते हैं एलिक्स एप
है इसको पहले तो अनजिप कर लेते हैं चल
भाई अच्छा अज भी नहीं होगा ना
अच्छा अनजिप अनजिप अनजिप अन अन अनजिप
इंस्टॉल जिप डे
बियन इसकी पात यह कौन सी है इसकी पैकेज
बाइनरी क्या है पैकेज भाई व्ट इ द पैकेज
पैकेज क्या गया ओके जिप पैकेज ही है जिप ए
इंस्टॉल
जिप जिप को इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं तभी जिप
कर
पाएंगे ओके लेट्स इंस्टॉल जिप तो हमारा
जिप इंस्टॉल हो चुका है अब हम एस करते हैं
यहां पे एएस ये दिख रहा होगा
नहीं है इसकी तो अब इसको हम अनजिप कर
लेंगे तो अनजिप एंड ए
मैस हो गया अब यहां पे एक बाइनरी आ गई
होगी एस की देखो यहां पे एस की बाइनरी आई
है क्या ए देखो एस
[संगीत]
कर लो सीपी कर लो ठीक है सीपी कर लो कॉपी
कर लो या जो भी आपको करना है ए मैं इस को
कर लेते हैं कहां पे यूएसआर
शेयर नहीं यूएसआर लोकल बिन लोकल बिन अब
हमने इसमें इसको कॉपी कर लिया अब हम चलते
हैं सीडी यूएसआर लोकल बिन में एंड यहां
देखते हैं हमें एमस मिल गया अब हम एमएस को
यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट करने की कोशिश करते
हैं और एस डन ना एग्जीक्यूट हो चुका है
एंड वी गॉट द
एस तो हमारा एमस बिल्कुल परफेक्टली काम कर
रहा है भैया देख लीजिए एस
को हम क्यों उस बिना डायरेक्टरी में गए भी
यहां से हम एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं बताइए
जबकि इंस्टॉल नहीं किया था
हमने
बताइए क्यों कर सकते
हैं बताइए जल्दी क्वेश्चन का आंसर
दीजिए
यह देखिए मेरे मेरे रेफरल
से 15 लोगों ने अभी तक साइन अप किया है
बढ़िया है 15 लोगों ने किया है और भी लोग
जितने लोग हैं कर
लीजिएगा तो ज्यादा टेंशन 15 लोगों ने किया
48 लोगों ने क्लिक किया 15 लोगों ने किया
है इसमें आ रहा है कि $75 मुझे मिलेंगे
लेकिन वो भाई कब मिलेंगे पता है जब आप $
स्पेंड करेंगे समझ में आ रहा है $5 आप
स्पेंड करेंगे तभी ये सब लोग करेंगे तब तो
खुश मत हो जाना कि ये 375 मुझे मिल गए हैं
काश मिल जाते मजा आ जाता लेकिन नहीं
मिलेंगे यार जब तक तुम 25 नहीं का खर्च
करोगे मुझे नहीं लगता तुम में से कोई $
खर्च करने वाला है तो कोई बात नहीं कोई
टेंशन नहीं आपका भला हो जाए आपको $200 मिल
जा रहे हैं बस काफी है एंजॉय कीजिए मस्ती
में रहिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है ठीक है हां जी अब यह इसलिए हुआ क्योंकि
आपका पा जो है ना व सेट है उस पर्टिकुलर
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
का वहां प जो भी टूल को आप भेजेंगे वो
एग्जीक्यूटेबल की तरह एग्जीक्यूट होगा
कैसे भैया हम इको करते हैं डॉलर सिंबल में
पाथ लिखते हैं एंटर करते हैं तो जितने भी
पाथ है वो आपके सामने आ जाएंगे एक पाथ है
आपका यूएसआर लोकल एस बिन यहां है एक पाथ
आपका यूएसआर लोकल बिन जिसमें हमने अभी
भेजा यह भी आपका पाथ है एक है यूएसआर एस
बिन
ये भी पात है यूएसआर बिन आप यूएसआर बिन
में भी भेज देंगे ना तो भी आपका
एग्जीक्यूट होगा एस बिन या बिन में ओनली
बिन में भेज दीजिए उसके एग्जीक्यूटेबल को
तो भी मतलब उसके बाइनरी को तो भी वो
एग्जीक्यूट होगा या आप यहां भी कहीं भी
भेज दीजिए आप पाथ जो सेट है वहां पे वो एज
एग्जीक्यूटेबल एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा भैया
इतना समझ में आ रहा है गट इट ओके यस सबसे
पहला जो आंसर आया मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं नॉट अवेलेबल काया पाथ सेट है थारा भाई
जोगिंदर पाथ शैलेश शैलेश कुमार पाथ सेट है
इसलिए ठीक है देन दर्शन इज आल्सो देयर
तान्या इज आल्सो देयर लक इज आल्सो देयर
एंड देन टेक माइन ओके ग्रेट ओके ग्रेट
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया जिन्होंने भी आंसर कराया
ट्स ग्रेट ऑफ यू
ओके बहुत बढ़िया अब देखिए ये तो आपका समझ
में आ गया होगा टूल्स सारे इंस्टॉल होने
लगे हो रहे हैं आराम से हो गए हैं बहुत
सारे हमने बीच में पॉज कर दिया था याद
रखिएगा तो कुछ टूल्स जो नहीं हुए होंगे वो
नहीं हुए होंगे कोई बात नहीं बाकी आप सारे
टूल्स को इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं आई विटनेस
इंस्टॉल हुआ है क्या नहीं हुआ आई विटनेस
तो नहीं है अब मान लो कोई अलग से टूल आपको
इंस्टॉल करनी है अलग से ठीक है लेट्स सपोज
आपको अलग से कोई टूल इंस्टॉल करनी है बहुत
सिंपल है आपको स्क्रीनशॉटिंग के लिए टूल
इंस्टॉल करनी है या सब फाइंडर इंस्टॉल
करना है चलो मुझे करना है सब फाइंडर ये
पता नहीं इंस्टॉल हुआ कि नहीं सब फाइंडर
लेट्स सी सब
फाइंडर नहीं इंस्टॉल हुआ है ठीक है मुझे
अब अलग से ये इंस्टॉल करना है चलिए तो मैं
सब फाइंडर के रिपोजिटरी पे आऊंगा अलग से
एक-एक टूल जो आपको यूज करना है ना वही
इंस्टॉल कीजिए ज्यादा बेटर होता है आपके
वीपीएस पे बहुत ज्यादा कचरा भरने की आपको
जरूरत नहीं है सब फाइंडर पे आ गया अब यहां
पे नीचे आऊंगा इंस्टॉलेशन की क्या
इंस्टॉलेशन है भैया किस तरह से करना है ये
देखिए ये गो का गो का गो में लिखा हुआ एक
कोड टूल है कॉपी किया यहां से गो हमारा
इंस्टॉल है ही यहां पे हमने एंटर कर दिया
गो का पाथ भी सेट है एंटर कर दिया एंड
दैट्ची
ओके व्हाट इज द
इशू पैकेज क्रिप्टो ई सीडीएच इज नॉट इन
गोरूट ओके गो रूट में य पैकेज नहीं है
ओके
ओके लेट्स गो हियर लेट्स गो टू द
इश्यूज ओपन इश्यूज में कुछ
है नहीं टू क्लोज में शायद है
ये
यस ठीक
है ओके रिलेटेड टू पैकेज ठीक
है ओके तो यहां पे आया यहां पे आ रहा है
लाइक इनका पैकेज क्लीन का कुछ आ रहा है
ठीक है तो एक बार पैकेज क्लीन का एक बार
देख लेते हैं लेट्स
ट्राई गो क्लीन मड
कैश ओके डन नाउ अगेन गिविंग द सेम
कमांड एंटर एंड
दैट्ची आपने देखा यहां पे एक एरर हमें आ
रही थी पहले अ क्या एरर आ रही थी अ हमें
एरर आई थी ये वाली
देखिए इस तरीके से एरर्स को सॉल्व किया
जाता है मैं आपको इसलिए बोलता हूं एरर
सॉल्विंग आना चाहिए ये वाला पैकेज
क्रिप्टो ई सीडीए इज नॉट इन गो रूट
दैट्ची स्ट्रिंग्स वाले आ गए तो हमने पहला
वाला ओपन किया एंड सेम प्र सेम एरर किसी
का आया हुआ था एंड यहां पे इन्होंने बताया
कि गो क्लीन मोड कस्ट
कीजिए एंड आपका हो जाएगा ठीक है तो हमने
क्या किया गो क्लीन मोड कस्ट किया एंड
हमारा ये एरर सॉल्विंग हो तो एरर सॉल्विंग
जो है वो आपके अंदर अगर नहीं है तो वह भी
एक बहुत बड़ी आपकी लाइक डीमेट आप बोल सकते
हैं आपके अंदर प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग स्किल्स
तो होने
चाहिए जितनी ज्यादा प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग
स्किल्स होंगी आप उतने ही अच्छे से कोई भी
प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व कर पाएंगे एंड आप जो है उस
लाइक चीज को आप लाइक चला पाएंगे ठीक है आप
बढ़िया से कर पाएंगे उसको अब यहां पर हम
यहां पर सब फाइंडर लिखते हैं सब फाइंडर
इंस्टॉल तो हो चुका
है
आई थिंक सही से इंस्टॉलेशन नहीं हुई थी ना
वो ऑटोमेट ऑटोमेटिक टूल वाली इसलिए ये हो
रहा है एप्ट गो एप्ट
इंस्टॉल गो
गोलंग गो तो है ही नहीं है भाई गोलंग एक
बार देख लेते हैं ठीक है
एंड ठीक है ओके सब
फाइंडर अब चलते हैं सीडी अ गो में यहां पे
गो के अंदर चलते हैं एलएस करते हैं यहां
पे सीडी बिन के अंदर चलते हैं
कुछ पाथ का कुछ इशू अभी तो आ रहा होगा
शायद बट यहां पर सब फाइंडर को देखते एक
बार सब फाइंडर सब फाइंडर नॉट
यर नॉट र स फंड नॉट
र लेटस वर्जन ठीक है ओके लेट्स एक्सक्यूट
ट लेट्स ट्राई टू
अगेन मैं अगेन एक बार ट्राई कर लेता हूं
देर माइट बी सम इशू मैं एक बार अगेन यहां
पर हम रन कर लेते हैं ठीक है एक बार अगेन
हम आते हैं यहां
पर गो इज अ वेरी
ग्रेट ग्रेट लैंग्वेज काफी बढ़िया
लैंग्वेज है यहां पर गो किसी भी टूल्स के
काफी इजी जो है आप इसमें राइट कर सकते हो
गो में तो लेट्स
ट्राई इट्स डाउनलोडिंग
डाउनलोडिंग लास्ट तक कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
आनी चाहिए तो डाउनलोडिंग हो रही है य सब
फाइंडर तो इस वाले स्क्रिप्ट में भी होगा
ना शायद कुछ
[संगीत]
कोलप्पा
इंडरली क्शन हो रही है यहां पे यस ट्स
इट कंफ्लेक्स इज देयर ट्स वई दिस इज
हैपनिंग चलिए यहां प इशू प चल देते हैं एक
बार ए ए
या अगेन गोइंग हियर एंड पैकेज
क्रिप्टो पैकेज क्रिप्टो ईसीडीए इ नॉट इन
गोरूट यूएस
आर लिब के अंदर गो है यूएस लिप के अंदर गो
ठीक है एक बार हम देख लेते हैं अरवाज हम
इसको रख देंगे गो रूट में डाल देंगे इसको
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है मैनुअली डाल के देख
लेंगे इंस्टॉलेशन एरर आ रही है बग बग यहां
पर आ रहा है यह बग कंसीडर हुआ है ओके सच
में पैकेज स्क्रिप्टो इ नॉट प्लीज
रिजॉल्वड क्या रिजॉल्व
भाई
ओके
ओके ए ड आ रहा है यहां
पर ठीक है लेट्स डू वन थिंग यहां पर क्या
है यूएसआर लिब के अंदर एक बार यहां पर चल
देते हैं कोड पे
[संगीत]
एंड स फाइंडर वजन टू लेट्स गो
नटू
ओके एक काम करते हैं यूएसआर लिब के अंदर
गो के अंदर चल लेते हैं गो का कुछ इशू
शायद हो सकता है मे बी ओके सीडी यूएस
लिब लिब के अंदर चलते हैं यहां पर गो इज
देर गो यस गो 1.19 ओके गो 1.19 ओके गो
1.19 एलस करते हैं यहां पे एंड जो लोकेशन
है वो कहां पर है भैया आपकी एसआरसी में है
तो सीडी एसआरसी चल लेते हैं एलस कर लेते
हैं एसआरसी के अंदर क्रिप्टो सीडी
क्रिप्टो के अंदर एलस करते हैं एंड देयर
इज द फाइल ट फाइल इज
ईसीडीए पैकेज क्रिप्टो सडी इज नॉट इन द गो
रूट ठीक है डीच कहां है भैया डीच डीच डीच
र इ डी एच कहां है
ये ई सडी एस ए तो है डीच कहां है
यार क्रिप्टो के अंदर ही तो है ना
क्रिप्टो के अंदर हम आ चुके
हैं कहीं पर आपको ईसीडीएस दिख रहा है
क्या आर यू सी ईसीडीए कहीं
पे आर यू सींग ईसीडीएस पैकेज कहीं पे मुझे
कहीं ईसीडीएस तो नहीं दिख रहा मैं एलस
करता हूं ग्रब ई सीडी
एच कुछ भी नहीं है भाई
ओके पैकेज क्रिप्टो ई सीडीएच इज नॉट इन
गोरूट एसआरसी क्रिप्टो
ईसीडीए
नोप्स कहीं पे नहीं है
डीए ओके लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड समथिंग यहां
इश्यूज प चलते हैं एंड ई स डी ए नॉट
प्रेजेंट लेट्स ट्राई ईसीडीए ईसीडीए ओनली
सर्च करके देखते हैं कुछ है क्या थ्री
क्लोज में आता है यहां
पे यह तो सेम वही चीज आ रही है लग रहा है
मुझे ओके ओके ओके आई कुड नॉट रेपो ऑन ठीक
है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है नीचे आ जा नीचे
आा ओके ओके ओके ओके बस बस
भाई
क्
गो अच्छा कौन सा वर्जन है पहले गो का गो
वर्जन देख लेते एक
बार 1.19 ए ठीक है ग वर्जन के साथ कुछ इशू
है क्या 1.2 1.21
ओके
ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके द टूल इंश्योर टू वर्क विद गो पॉइंट
1.21 ओके ग गो 1.21 के साथ हो रही
है ओके यह प्रॉब्लम है मतलब दिस इज द
वर्जन गो वर्जन इशू और कुछ भी नहीं
[संगीत]
है डे टू के लेक्चर नहीं देखा मु समझ नहीं
आरे डे टू का लेक्चर देखो
देखो यहां पर वर्जन इशू है कुछ यहां पर
लेट्स
सी ओके स फाइंडर प आते यहां पर यहां पर चल
जाते हैं रिलीजस पे एंड सब फाइंडर का अभी
जो है हमारे पास सब फाइंडर जैसे यह अभी
कोई भी सब फाइंडर अभी तो हमारा नहीं आया
ना सब फाइंडर यहां
पर ओके लेट्स लेट्स डू वन थिंग लेट्स डू
वन
थिंग यहां चलते हैं
ओके
अपडेट अपडेट तो क्या करेंगे यार क्योंकि
अपडेट तो करने की रिक्वायरमेंट ही नहीं है
ना हमें तो गो का छोटा वाला वर्जन चाहिए
छोटू
वाला इंस्टल गोलंग
1.21 1.21 हा 1.21 हा काफी है 1.21 ही कर
लेते
हैं 1.21 ही कर लेते हैं
यह वाला वर्जन है य ना यह वाला वर्जन
है यस यस यस दिस वर्जन इ देयर जो हम अभी
यहां पर कर सकते हैं बेसिकली तो हमें यहां
पर ओके एक काम करते हैं यहां पर
एट एप्ट लिस्ट गो देखते हैं गोलंग तो होगा
ना गोलंग क्या यह गोलंग एक है वर्जन इज
1.9 वर्जन है 1.19 वाली वर्जन है नाउ टू
ओके ना स् वाली वर्जन है ठीक है हम एक काम
करते हैं लेट्स रपट रिमूव गोलंग एक बार
गोलंग को हटा के देखते हैं लेट्स रिमूव
दिस गोलंग एक बार वंस अगेन एंड यहां पर अब
शायद यहां पर एलस में गो तो नहीं
आएगा आ रहा है यहां पर तो एक काम करते हैं
एट पर्स
गोलंग
ओके एट ऑटो रिमूव कुछ का है उसको हटा देते
हैं जो रिक्वायर्ड नहीं है उनको हटा देते
हैं हमारे यहां
पे वीपीएस को जीआई मोड प एक्सेस मत करो
बर्बाद हो जाओगे भाई एक मिनट में ठीक है
एलएस करते हैं यहां पे सीडी गो एलएस एंड
सीडी बिन एंड आई थिंक देर शुड नॉट बी ओके
यह रही हमारी ओके चलिए तो अब यहां पर गो
करते हैं यहां पर गो लैंग ठीक है गो गो तो
गया भाई आपका सॉरी गो गया अब यहां से अगर
हम लेट्स ब्रिंग आउट द सब फाइंडर ठीक है
सब फाइंडर प आते हैं लेट्स गो यर एंड गो
लैंग वाली कहां गई भैया हमारी इसकी कमांड
कमांड कहां गई गोलंग
वाली यह वाली गो इंस्टॉल कमांड हमने लिया
एंड यहां हमने पेस्ट किया एंटर किया एंड
यस नो सच नो सच फाइल और डायरेक्टरी यूएसआर
बिन गो यहां पर हमारा जो है वो नहीं है
ठीक है अब जो है इसको हम क्या कर देते हैं
यहां
पे आर एम हान आर
गो ओके सो हमने गो को भी रिमूव कर दिया
टोटली ठीक है भैया ट्स इट गो का हमने और
टूल्स वाला जो भी है वो सारा चीज हमने
रिमूव कर दिया है खत्म कहानी अब हम इसकी
एक पर्टिकुलर इंस्टेंस वर्जन को करते हैं
ट्राई यहां पे लेट्स गो टू डब्लू गेट
डाउनलोड करके डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट कर
देते हैं एंड देखते हैं कि व्ट इज हैपनिंग
राइट तो चलिए हमने गो का यह वाला वर्जन जो
है डाउनलोड
किया एंड यह वर्जन हमारा एलस आ चुकी है
हमारे
पास ठीक है इसको हम एक्सट्रैक्ट कर
लेंगे सॉरी इसको वी आर गोइंग टू
एक्सट्रैक्ट हा जी तो इसको हमने
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर
लिया
[संगीत]
दैट्ची
यहां पे हमने दिया पाथ एंड यूएसआर लोकल इज
देर पाथ यूएसआर लोकल यूएस आर लोकल पाथ
नहीं है बेसिकली द पाथ इज यूस आ लोकल
गोबिन ठीक है वो तो अलग लोकल के अंदर का
गो एंड बिन हमने कर दिया तो यूएसआर लोकल
को हम यस यस यस यूएसआर लोकल जो है उसके
अंदर गो बिन है हमारा तो इसको हम क्या कर
देते हैं थोड़ी टाइम के लिए इसको हम रिमूव
कर देते हैं यहां से वी हैव द पाथ सो हम
क्या करते
कैट करते हैं सॉरी यहां पर हम कर देते हैं
विम विम चलेगा क्या आई डोंट थिंक ओके ओके
ओके ओके ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट तो हम कर
देते हैं एल एस हान ए एंड विम करते हैं
एंड हमारा कहां प था यह बैश आरसी में बैश
सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी डॉट बश आर स एंटर करते हैं
हम यहां पर आ जाते हैं यह एक्सपोर्ट पाथ
में आपको दिख रहा
होगा यर यू कैन सी बस इसी पाथ में आपको
सेट कर देना है और तो कुछ नहीं है पाथ में
ऑलरेडी यूस लोकल ब सेट है बढ़िया चलिए अ
पाथ सेट कर देते हैं यहां
पे फिलहाल के लिए सीडीयस आर स् लोकल में
चलते हैं एलएस करते हैं एंड यहां पे आपको
गो मिल जाएगा इस गो को आपको हटा देना
पड़ेगा तो हम करते हैं आरएम हाफ आर एंड गो
एंड
दैट्ची पाथ में आ चुका है यहां पे ऑलरेडी
ओके कोई पाथ नहीं है वी विल बी रिमूविंग
दिस विम अ स्ल रूट स् बैश आर स एंड डन एंड
यहां पे हम आई बटन प्रेस करके हम इसको
पहले फिलहाल पाच से यहां हटा देंगे फिर यह
पाथ सेट हो जाएगा टेंशन नहीं लेना है
ज्यादा यहां पे यूएसआर
लोकल
गोबिन यह हटा देते हैं ठीक है अभी हमारा
जो है यह पाथ जो है नॉर्मल सा सेट है यह
हमारा पाथ सेट रहेगा अब हम यहां पे क्या
कर देंगे सोर्स करेंगे जब भी आप कोई
प्रोफाइल में बैश आरसी या प्रोफाइल में
कोई चेंजेज करते हैं तो आपको यहां पर
बेसिकली सोर्स करना पड़ता है
तो रूट डॉट बैश आरसी तब वो अपडेट हो जाता
है तो हमने कर दिया एंड ट्स इट अब हम यहां
पर अगर पाथ को देखेंगे इ को एंड यहां पर
अगर हमने पाथ
दिया सॉरी ये हमने दिया तो अब यहां पर
आपको वो वाली पात नहीं दिखेगी अब हम
सिंपली क्या करेंगे भ या वी आर गोइंग टू
एग्जीक्यूट दिस ठीक है क्या करेंगे हम मूव
करेंगे कहां गो को कहां पर करेंगे यूएसआर
लोकल में मूव कर देंगे तो एलस करते यहां
पे ए य प गो आ चुका है आपका अब यहां पर एम
भी कर देंगे गो को स्ल यूएसआर एंड स्ल
लोकल य बाइनरी है ना यार बाइनरी है ना देख
लेते हैं सीडी गो बाइनरी तो नहीं है यार
यहां पर यहां पर गो का बाइनरी होगा ना कोई
गो
बाइनरी
बाइनरी सीडी बिन एल एस यस यह रही बाइनरी
तो यह बाइनरी को बेसिकली क्या ये जो मूव
करने का आ रहा है ना मूव गो यहां पे आपको
दिख रहा होगा ये मूव गो का मतलब ये बाइनरी
को गो करने ये बता रहे हैं कि बाइनरी को
लेके जाइए पूरा डायरेक्टरी को लेके नहीं
जाना है आपको या बाइनरी को आपको लेके जाना
है लोकल यूएसआर एंड लोकल के अंदर में ठीक
है तो ये बाइनरी को हम मूव करेंगे बीन के
अंदर जो हमारा ये बाइनरी है दैट इट इस
वाले बाइनरी को ठीक है तो हम क्या कर देते
हैं यहां से बिन वाले इस डायरेक्टरी से
यहां पे कॉपी कर देते हैं गो को एंड
यूएसआर के अंदर लोकल के अंदर कॉपी कर देते
हैं ठीक है
[संगीत]
दैट्ची आपने सेट करा होगा एक्सपोर्ट ये कर
दीजिए एंड उसके बाद आप सोर्स कर दीजिए
[संगीत]
दैट्ची के लिए एंड
दैट्ची क आउट कर लेते हैं तो विम कर लेते
हैं या कैट कर लो जो भी करना है विम कर
लेते हैं स्ल रूट स्ड ब
आरसी एंटर कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स
सी इफ वी हैव गिवन द एंट्री
हियर कहां पे हमने एंट्री दे दी
है ठीक है
सीडी एल एस हान ए प्रोफाइल में आ गई क्या
हमारी विड
प्राइल नॉप नॉप नॉप नॉप नप न नन इसको हम
कॉपी अभी तो चलो ये तो टेंपररी पाथ सेट हो
चुका है अगर आप गो पे क्लिक करेंगे तो
आपका ये क्लिक ये होके आ जाएगा आपका गो
ओपन हो जाएगा एंड अगर आपका
लाइक हमने यहां पे क्या किया यहां पे
बेसिकली गो पाथ ठीक है तो अगर हमने इ को
किया एंड यहां पे हमने गो पाथ देखा तो
हमें ये रूट गो ये वाली आपकी पाथ है ये
टेंपररी है अगर सेम चीजों को आप परमानेंट
करना चाहते हैं आपको सिंपली ये जो चीजें
हैं ये बैश आरसी प्रोफाइल में ले जाके
कॉपी मार देनी है बस और कुछ भी नहीं करना
है मैंने जैसे यहां से कॉपी मारा मैं क्या
करूंगा यहां पे सिंपली यहां पे पेस्ट मार
दूंगा एंड मैं क्या कर देता हूं देखो कैसे
करना है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं इसको
परमानेंट अगर आपको करना है तो सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है इसको कॉपी मार लिए यहां
पे यहां पे आपको कॉपी मारना है लेट्स सी
देखते जाइए एंड यहां पे आपकी प्रोफाइल में
जैसे जो आपकी बैस प्रोफाइल है एलएस आफ ए
किया बैश आरसी है आप उसमें भी आप उसमें
डाल सकते हैं विम किया डॉट ब आरसी एंड
एंटर किया अब हम यहां पे नीचे आएंगे नीचे
आएंगे नीचे आएंगे सिंपल सा एंड यहां
जाएंगे इंसर्ट मोड को ऑन कर देते हैं यस
एंटर एंड यहां पे हमने पेस्ट कर दिया चलिए
ये पाथ सेट हो गया आपका अब यहां पे कॉलन
डबल क देके सेव एंड एग्जिट कर देंगे एंड
यहां पे कर देंगे
सोर्स डॉट बै आरसी तो ये आपका सोर्स हो
गया हो गया अब जो है आपका गो पाथ बिल्कुल
सेट है गो पे क्लिक कीजिए गो लिखिए एंटर
कीजिए दैट्ची खत्म आपका गो जो है बिल्कुल
सेट हो चुका है यूएसआर लोकल कहां पे सेट
हुआ है भैया अ ये गोपा
सीडी ये अभी क्या है पीडब्ल्यूडी आपका रूट
में है आपका गो पाथ आपने कहां पे सेट किया
है ये देखो ये सेट किया है यूएसआर लोकल के
अंदर गो ठीक है यूएसआर लोकल के अंदर या
फिर आपकी जो होम डायरेक्टरी है रूट के
अंदर तो रूट गो स्ल रूट गो आप यानी कि
यहां पे रूट के अंदर आपको गो मिल जाएगी
आपको ठीक है ट्स इट चलिए यह तो काम हो गया
अब गो वर्जन चेक कर लीजिए हमने गो वर्जन
देख लेते
हैं कैन नॉट फाइंड गोरु डायरेक्टरी यूएसआर
लोकल गो क्या बात है यार क्यों नहीं फाइंड
कर पा रहे
हो गो डायरेक्टरी तो मेंशन है ना यूएसआर
लोकल गो तो फिर दिक्कत क्या है विम स् रूट
डॉट बैश आर
स
ओके
ओके ओके पाथ इ
यूसर ओके यहां पर आपका है यूएस लोकल गो गो
रूट जो है यहां पर गो पाथ जो है आपका होम
एंड गो है तो रूट के अंदर गो है ठीक है
एंड गो पा जो है आपने क्या दिक्कत आ रही
है क्या दिक्कत आ रही
है जस आरसी तो जस सेल के लिए है ना जस के
लिए है ना राइट तो यहां पर हमें दिक्कत आ
रही है कि कैन नॉट फाइंड गो रूट
डायरेक्टरी यूएस लोकल गो अच्छा गो रूट की
डायरेक्टरी बोल रहे हैं तो गो रूट में
यूएस लोकल गो यहां तो आ तो रहा है
य पाथ में आपका गो पाथ
है बिन में है गो पाथ तो आपका होम गो होम
गो बिन एंड गो रूट में बिन में है तो गो
रूट में यूएसआर लोकल गो
बिन ठीक
है सो व्हाट इज द इशू वी वी नीड टू मूव गो
डायरेक्टरी नॉट गो
बाइनरी अच्छा हमने बाइनरी मूव किया क्या
ओनली ओके ओके ओके
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके सो गाइस देखो अभी
क्या है हमने बाइनरी मूव कर दिया है कॉपी
नहीं किया हमने इसका गो का पूरा जो जो
यहां पे बेसिकली यहां पे ये जो है ना गो
यूजर लोकल में तो हमने ये बाइनरी को मूव
कर दिया हमने पूरा पैकेज मूव नहीं किया है
तो हम यहां पे कॉपी कर देते हैं एंड स्ल
यूएसआर स् लोकल में इसको भी कॉपी कर लेते
हैं ठीक है सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी यहां पे न
r दे देते हैं एंड यहां पे हमने कॉपी कर
दिया तो क्या कर रहा है कैन नॉट ओवरराइट
नॉन डायरेक्टरी यूआ लोकल गो वि डायरेक्टरी
गो ओके क्यों भाई ऐसा क्यों भाई ओके एक
काम कर देते
हैं एलएस कर देते हैं एल एस एमवी एंड गो
को कर देते हैं स्ल यूएसआर स्ल लोकल एंड
कैन नॉट ओवरराइट ठीक है तो एक काम करते
सीडी स्ल
यूएसआर लोकल में चलते हैं ए एलएस करते हैं
यहां पे एंड ये जो गो है ये शायद आपकी
बाइनरी सीडी गो प क्लिक करेंगे नहीं जाएगा
क्योंकि ओबवियसली डायरेक्टरी नहीं है तो
हम एक काम कर देते हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू रिमूव आर एम गो
दैट्ची ओबवियसली रूट गो बिन गो यहां पे
थोड़ा सा गड़बड़ ये हो गया कि यहां पे
एलएस करते हैं यहां पे अब सीडी यूएसआर
लोकल पे चलते हैं एंड यहां पे हमारे को
यहां गो मिल जाता है तो सीडी अब ये जो गो
है गाइज सीडी
गो अब यहां पे आपको ये
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
तो हमने मूव कर दिया है एंड हमने ये सेम
चीजें एक्सपोर्ट यूएसआर लोकल गो एंड यहां
पे आपका ये वाला जो कमांड है ये सारी
कमांड जो है आपको चलानी है एंड आपको
प्रोफाइल में ये वाली चीज डाल देनी है
[संगीत]
दैट्ची गो हमें हमें गो मिल चुका है यहां
पे एंड वी गॉट द गो यहां पे अब जो है हम
इससे एग्जीक्यूट कर करके देखते हैं गो
वर्जन एंड लेट्स ट्राई गो वर्जन
1.2.1 वी गट द 1.2.1 वर्जन हम सक्सेसफुली
यहां पे आ चुके हैं अब यहां पे हम क्या
करते हैं सब फाइंडर वी नीड टू इंस्टॉल सब
फाइंडर तो हम सब फाइंडर को उठा के लेके
आते हैं कि देखते हैं क्या होता है भाई सब
फाइंडर का कुछ हो पाता है कि नहीं तो हम
यहां पे सब फाइंडर की इंस्टॉलेशन कमांड
हमने कॉपी की गो इंस्टॉल किया यहां पे एंड
लेट्स
वेट
ओके इट्स डाउन लोडिंग डूइंग इट्स वर्क
देखते
हैं कर लिया अभी हमने
अ या वी डिड इट ठीक है मनी
कांता नाउ लेट्स
ट्राई
इटस डूइंग ट वक लेट्स लेट इट फिनिश यस मण
कां डन डन डन
डन थैंक्स
ड्यूड
ओ कितने लोग हैं अभी ओनली 42 यार सब थक
जाते हैं यार सब थक जाते हैं मतलब देखा है
मैंने एवरीवन गेट्स टायर्ड बचारे टायर्ड
हो जाते हैं
कोई बात नहीं
चलिए लेट इट
[संगीत]
फिनिश इसलिए लॉट्स ऑफ गो टूल इसलिए बनते
है क्य गो इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज काफी इजी भी है एंड
काफी ज्यादा लाइक यू कैन से अ क्रॉस
प्लेटफॉर्म लैंग्वेज है काफी बढ़िया तरीके
से आप इसमें टूल्स को डेवलप कर पाते हो
इजी टू कोड है आपका तो दैट्ची लाइब्रेरीज
हैं गो इज अ वेरी वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल
ओके रन करके देखोगे लाइक देन पता चलेगा रन
करके
रन करके देखोगे ऐसा क्यों लग रहा है मैं
लेट हो गया हां अभी आए हो तब तो लेट हुए
हो भाई अभी अगर अभी आए हो तो लेट तो हुए
हो
राइट ओके लेट इट
फिनिश
चलिए यह हो गया हमारा अब यहां पर गाइस सब
फाइंडर लिख के और एंटर कीजिएगा एंड सब
फाइंडर विल स्टार्ट यहां पर भी नहीं आ रहा
हाई फने दे दीजिएगा सब फाइंडर आपका
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा एंड यू कैन जस्ट स्टार्ट
यूजिंग सब फाइंडर सो यू गट गाइस ट व्ट वी
ड हमने फाइनली सब फाइंडर को लंच कर दिया
है एंड जो सब फाइंडर है आप चला पा रहे
राइट सर कैसे आप इतना सोच लेते हैं कुछ हम
लोगों को भी एडवाइस दीजिए अरे भैया सोच
सोचना क्या है मतलब करते रहो करते रहो
जहां फसो वहां कर
लोगे स्पीड स्लो नहीं है भाई बहुत फास्ट
है यह टूल बहुत बड़ी है मतलब इंस्टॉलेशन
में काफी इसमें टाइम लगता है स्पीड बहुत
ज्यादा ही है तो फाइनली वी डिड फाइनली वी
हैव सब वाइनर ना फाइनली वी हैव सब फाइंडर
गाइस वी हैव द सब फाइंडर
राइट यह देखिए लच हो रही है सब फाइंडर बस
यहां प हान लगा दीजिएगा तो हान ये आ जाएगी
आपकी ठीक है एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड नाउ वी यू
कैन गेट द डोमस एंड यू कैन गेट द सब
डोमेंस जो आप करते आ रहे हैं बेसिकली वही
आप करेंगे बस
[संगीत]
दैट्ची
वी आर डन नाउ इट्स गिविंग द रिजल्ट्स एंड
दैट इट 5300 यह देखो 5379 5 5379 सब डोमस
इनमेट हो चुके हैं इसके भाई google2
राइट ओके
चलिए ओके सो दिस वे यू इंस्टॉल यू
कॉन्फिडो डिजिटल ओसन पे आपने यह कन्फेशन
कर ली है मैंने आपको लिंक दे दिया है आप
लिंक से जैसे ही आएंगे मैं वापस लिंक दे
देता हूं डिजिटल ओसन का ये पिंड है आपके
पिंड लिंक भी दिख जाएगी देख लीजिए जो चैट
में पिंड लिंक है आप उस परे जाएंगे यह
मेरा रेफर लिंक है ओबवियसली एंड उससे साइन
अप जब कर लेंगे तो आप डिजिटल ओसन का
अकाउंट क्रिएट कर सेंगे तो आपको $200 जो
है क्रेडिट मिल जाता है जिसको आप दो महीने
में यूज करेंगे दो महीने तक आपका रहेगा
उसके बाद आपका चार्ज लगता है इसमें तो
जैसा जैसे यूज करेंगे वो हमने अभी $ पर
मंथ वाला मशीन यूज किया है तो उसके
अकॉर्डिंग ही चार्ज करेगा राइट उसके
अकॉर्डिंग ही क्या होगा ये चार्ज करेगा
राइट
ओके हा समझ में आ गया होगा
आपको चलिए एवरीथिंग यू अंडरस्टूड काफी कम
लोग लास्ट में रह गए बेचारे समझ नहीं पा
रहे मेरे ल से ठीक है कोई बात नहीं आप लोग
दोबारा देखिएगा समझ में आ जाएगा
ओके ओके ग्रेट अब यहां पर आपको गो पाथ
देखना है इको कर दीजिए यहां पर एंड यहां
पर डॉलर गो पाथ आप यहां पे देख लीजिए रूट
गो है यानी कि अब जब आप सीडी रूट गो में
जाएंगे तो आपको यहां पे एक बिन का पैकेज
मिलना चाहिए ये बिन आपको मिल रहा है यहां
पे सीडी बिन एंड इसके अंदर जो भी टूल्स है
वो आपके इंस्टॉल होंगे जो भी जैसे सब
फाइंड इंस्टॉल हुआ तो ये आपका इंस्टॉल हो
गया है ठीक है इको एंड गो रूट यहां पे
यूएसआर लोकल गो है यह आपका गो रूट
डायरेक्टरी जो है वो आपका है गो रूट
डायरेक्टरी मतलब रूट जहां पे ये गो है
अवेलेबल है तो आप जब जाएंगे सीडी यूएसआर
यूएसआर लोकल एंड इसमें जाएंगे तो आपको गो
मिल जाएगा यहां पे ये
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
कीजिएगा एंड क्या कीजिएगा विम
स्ल रूट ड ब आरसी इसमें जाइएगा एंड यहां
पर आप इसको यहां पर किस तरीके से इस तरीके
से यहां पर जैसे ये लिखा हुआ है ना यहां
पे ये इस तरीके से पेस्ट कर दीजिएगा और
उसके बाद डब्लू क्य करके सेव सेव एग्जिट
डबबल क का मतलब होता है और इसके बाद सोर्स
कर दीजिएगा सोर्स ठीक है एंड उसके बाद
आपका रूट डॉट बैश आरसी आरसी सॉरी बैश आरसी
एंड आपका यह काम हो जाएगा अब यहां पर फिर
से सब फाइंडर आप लंच कीजिएगा तो सब फाइंडर
आप किसी भी डायरेक्टरी से मतलब सॉरी किसी
भी लोकेशन से अब सा फाइंडर को आप लच कर
सकते हैं अब आराम से य आपका लच हो जाएगा
ट्स इट ठीक है तो ट्स इट गाइस थैंक यू
आरसी टेक ओ हो क्या बात है भाई क्या बात
है आरसी टेक क्या बात है
[संगीत]
आरटेक र की र की मिली हमें सुपर चट थैंक
यू ब्रदर थैंक
यू
चलिए
तो भाई आपकी परमिशन हो तो मैं इसको गाली
दूं या बहुत भक नहीं जाने दो कोई बात नहीं
बहुत लोग ऐसे मिलते हैं ब्रदर काफी लोग
ऐसे मिलते हैं जो इस तरीके की हरकतें करते
हैं हमें उनको इग्नोर करना चाहिए ठीक है
ना हमें उनको इग्नोर करना चाहिए बस ठीक
है सत्य पराजित हो सकता है बट सत्य पराजित
नहीं हो सकता है मतलब थोड़ा सा उल्टा बोल
दिया इसका जो ऐसा है सत्य परेशान हो सकता
है पराजित नहीं तो इनको जो काम है इनका
करने दो और एक कहावत है हाथी चले बाजार
कुत्ते भोके हजार तो उस कहावत को उस अ
प्रोवर्ब को मैं बहुत ज्यादा मानता हूं तो
इसलिए मैं ज्यादा माइंड नहीं करता हूं ठीक
है
दैट्ची कर सकते हैं एंड अपनी खुद की
वीपीएस क्लाउड सर्विस क्लाउड मशीन को चला
सकते हैं उसमें बग बाउंट के लिए ये यूज़
कर सकते हैं सभी लोग कर लेंगे जल्दी से एक
बार बता दीजिए देन हम इसको एंड करेंगे
जल्दी से बता दीजिए मुझे फटाफट बता दीजिए
फटाफट एवरीवन प्लीज सभी लोग कर
लेंगे सभी लोग कर लेंगे ना बिल्कुल
परफेक्टली
ओके चलिए सभी लोग कर लेंगे ग्रेट ग्रेट
चलिए इतना कर लीजिएगा लिंक आपको इस लाइव
के डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी रेफर लिंक मिल
जाएगी चैट में पिन कमेंट में तो है ही
आपके पिन चैट में बाकी आप वहां से जाके कर
लीजिएगा $200 का आपको क्रेडिट मिलेगा दो
महीने एकदम मस्त एंजॉय कीजिए यूज़ कीजिए
ठीक है एंड इसको आप रिपीट कीजिए इसको आप अ
लाइक इस चीज को प्रैक्टिस कीजिए जितना
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे उतना ज्यादा बढ़िया होगा
आपके लिए एंड अगेन आई एम सेइंग ये डिजिटल
फॉरन सिक्स की हमारी मास्टरी ट्रेनिंग बैच
लाइव ट्रेनिंग थ्री मंथ्स की जो है वो
स्टार्ट होने वाली है 27th जैन से तो एक
आपके पास लास्ट अपॉर्चुनिटी है सात सीट्स
जो है थे वो बचे हुए थे जिसमें से एक और
इनरोलमेंट हमारे पास आई है यानी छह सीट्स
अभी बचे हुए हैं एंड आप इसमें आके इनरोल
कर सकते हैं ठीक है आपको लिंक भी चैट में
दे दिया है थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू इट्स
क्वाइट इजी यस इट्स क्वाइट इजी देन
amazonaws.com
ड्रॉपलेट प क्लिक कीजिए यहां से आप ऑफ कर
दीजिए या तो आप अपने मशीन में जिसमें
लॉगइन है यहां पे आप शट डाउन हाइन एच नाउ
कमांड चला दीजिए यहां से भी आप इस मशीन को
शट डाउन कर सकते हैं जैसे ही मैंने शट
डाउन किया देखो कनेक्शन क्लोज हो गई खत्म
एंड यहां पे जब आप इसको रीलोड करेंगे तो
ये जो अभी ग्रीन सिंबल दिख रहा है ना य
एक्टिव का ये ग्रे हो जाएगा यानी
इनक्टो हो गया ऑफ हो गया ऑटोमेटिक तो आपने
वहां से ऑफ कर दिया
दैट्ची ओके गाइस
दैट्ची एंजॉयड यू लाइक लर्न समथिंग आप
अपने दोस्तों के बीच शेयर जरूर कीजिए एंड
हमारे जो भी आप बेसिकली प्रैक्टिस करना है
आपको जो भी आपको बताया गया था अभी तक आपको
उसको प्रैक्टिस करना है कंप्लीट करना है
एक सिंपल सा आपको मैं टास्क दे देता हूं
एंड यह टास्क आपको पहले भी दिया है बट
स्टिल मैं आपको यह रिपीट कर रहा हूं यह
टास्क ठीक है प्लीज इसको ध्यान में रख के
कीजिएगा
आप आ जाइए ट्राई है मी पे आ जाइएगा ट्राई
हैक मी पे लर्न पे आ जाइएगा एंड लर्न पे
जब आएंगे तो आपको कुछ लर्निंग पथ्स
मिलेंगे इस लर्निंग पाथ में आपको यह वाली
पाथ प्री सिक्योरिटी पाथ पूरी कंप्लीट
करनी है एंड देन यू हैव टू मूव टू जूनियर
पेन पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर पहले प्री
सिक्योरिटी पूरी कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा यह
आपका एक टास्क है एंड जो लोग भी कंप्लीट
करेंगे लिंकन पे आप उसको डालिए एंड उसके
बाद आप हमारी पेज डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
जो है उसको टैग कीजिएगा या आप डायरेक्टली
मुझे भी टैग कर सकते सकते हैं टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर हैंडल के साथ एंड देन अ अ मुझे
पता चल जाएगा कि आपने वो काम किया है ठीक
है ओके टास्क किया चलिए बस इतना ही आज के
लिए गाइ थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन
इट वाज वंडरफुल सेशन अपने दोस्तों के बीच
सेशन को शेयर कीजिए अगर आप कुछ भी सीखने
सीखते हैं इस सेशन से कुछ भी आपको सीखने
को मिलता है धमाकेदार आपको कुछ लगता है
लगता है कि यू आर लर्निंग एक्चुअल बग
बाउंट फॉर फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट एंड आप एक प्रो
भी बनोगे जल्दी बनोगे आपके ऊपर है जितना
आप सिंसियर रहोगे जितना आप प्रैक्टिस
करोगे उतनी जल्दी आप बनोगे बस इना मुझे
पता है दैट्ची
है हां रहेंगे आपके वीपीएस पे ही रहेंगे
ऑफ ऑन करेंगे तो वीपीएस पे ही रहेंगे
टर्मिनेट करेंगे ना आप यहां से यहां से
आके डिस्ट्रॉय कर देंगे तब वो खत्म हो
जाएंगे एडब्ल्यू एस में टर्मिनेट कर देंगे
तो हट जाएगा शट डाउन कीजिएगा तब वो रहेगा
बट टर्मिनेट कर देंगे तो बिल्कुल खत्म हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो टर्मिनेट या इस तरीके से
आके डिस्ट्रॉय मत कर दीजिएगा बस शट डाउन
कर दीजिएगा ऑफ कर दीजिएगा दैट्ची है थैंक
यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन एंड आज का
सेशन यहां पे हम एंड करते हैं
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन में
नेक्स्ट क्लास में
धन्यवाद